all right scum and villainy
let's give it up for fat man beyond with
kevin smith and mark bernardin
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey
merry christmas and welcome to fat man
beyond i am director kevin smith
i am director mark bernard
[Applause]
just a quick [ __ ] uh apology like
they were working on the internet like
to get the feed up and running and stuff
and you know jc was like we gotta spawn
it's ready to go up i said how long you
got he's like a minute i was like a
minute minute he's like a minute
i was like that's enough time to smoke
another joint and i went out
and i just got it [ __ ] lit
and all of a sudden mark's like we're
going and i
[ __ ] had to chase him here on stage
so i wasted a perfectly good joint for
you people
happy to do it man we are here in
hollywood right on hollywood boulevard
at the scum and villainy cantina let the
people at home know you are [ __ ] real
um so much to talk about uh but we
probably uh
should talk about a sponsor is that we
we got we got two tonight yeah who do
you want to do do you want to do
smelling good or [ __ ] hard
my god same exact question asked my wife
last night
um i will uh go uh let's go let's you
know i mean it's early in the evening it
is let's not go right to the [ __ ] let's
start with the nipples
all right let's go for smelling good
we'll do dick and hard halfway through
the show
when things have gotten a little loose
and saucy when you've had a few wakanda
forevers when we're all warmed up yes
exactly all right so smelling good that
starts us off
smelling good could only mean uh one
company the only company that gives a
[ __ ] about our podcast ladies and
gentlemen one of two and they're both
sponsored tonight give it up for our
sponsor our eternal [ __ ] sponsor the
one that makes us smell good and you
smell better
native ladies and gentlemen native
native d-e-o.com
and sharp eyes at home will notice how
quickly my eyes darted to the copy to
make sure
that it was native because as the word
came out of my mouth i was like that's
not it
and then thankfully he went native i was
like jesus [ __ ] christ i was chasing
that joint yeah my brain isn't on this
watch too i'm still out in the [ __ ]
back alley um native folks uh my god i
actually love this company i use their
product today before i came here and
showered and used native [ __ ] shampoo
so did i
well no i did the deodorant not the
shampoo do you use shampoo i do
you see your head
clean what do you use like a [ __ ]
thimblefoot yeah
no because i'm also still kind of 12 at
heart so i just do the whole lavender
did you use half a bottle of shampoo
maybe
why
i use shampoo like all here and then in
the middle there's just no point
whatsoever and [ __ ] there is like i feel
like that's where if we were in the
cartoon bugs bunny would be like
and then he would take out the little
strap
and grab some [ __ ] hair or flowers
i remember that cartoon correctly uh
native can practically do that grow
flowers
on your body that's how good this [ __ ]
smells man i can't sell this any better
than the folks who write their copy
let's see what the good folks at native
yes who write the copy
native she said
this week my god my mind is playing
trick something
this episode of cantina theater is
brought to you by nativedeo.com
there it is there it is try to remember
the intro my favorite part of the year
uh this year is the food i can never get
enough of how everything smells and
speaking of smells i have to tell you
about natives awesome new holiday
inspired scents and products they're no
manscaped
yeah it's it's you know you i could read
this copy to my mom and she'd be like oh
that's lovely yes and things smell good
yeah those things smell good that's true
i mean we'll get to the dickenheart
later which doesn't feel like it's
mom-approved copy yes generally they
tend to go with the raunchier jokes yes
so native cares about the products you
put on your body they're all about
stopping the stink the right way that's
the native difference you've heard us
talk about native natives legendary
aluminium-free deodorant
i like when you say i like that right
the british way man the guy richie way
it's aluminium yeah that's pretty cool
patrick stewart this far no further
native's mission is to overhaul your
entire hygiene routine by creating
products that are made with simple
ingredients like shea butter and coconut
oil so you can smell great all day long
with classics and rotating seasonals
native has a scent for everyone try
their holiday scented deodorant body
wash or toothpaste incense like candy
cane sugar cookie fresh mistletoe yeah i
can vouch for that man i [ __ ]
sugar cookie smells amazing i did an
episode where i licked it it was so
[ __ ] good
native wrote me a [ __ ] letter going
we're going to stop advertising if you
do [ __ ] like that again don't eat our
products don't look so [ __ ] good
yes giving the gift of self-care is easy
with native build yourself or your loved
ones personalized product bundles by
mixing and matching three of your
favorite holiday scented products into a
set
please mention which holiday items you
love most
a sugar cookie
all over my body man all over he's
supposed to use it in one place i use it
in all places and [ __ ] i want my [ __ ]
to smell like sugar cookies
shouldn't use it there but i do
he did it all for the cookie yeah the
cookie
the cookie
um yeah man [ __ ] there's your ad
right there native it'll make your
[ __ ] smell like sugar cookies
and i don't care who you are
your benefit from an [ __ ] smells like
sugar cookies you know at the very least
you're curious yeah the very least
people remember you like i don't know
much about him but [ __ ] did his [ __ ]
smell like sugar cookies and they're
like that's because he went native son
is he farting keebler elves
yes farting keeper elf that wouldn't
insinuate he ate one
yeah he did
i like your [ __ ] dark sensibility
filmmaker
hello filmmaker all right so top off
this cop top off the cubby stay merry
happy and fresh this holiday season you
will love natives limited time seasonal
products as much as i slash we do go to
nativedeo.com fat man or use promo code
fat mana check out and get 20 off your
first order that's nativedeo.com
fatman or use promo code fatman at
checkout for 20 off your first order
[ __ ] love native literally love
native use its product all the time
can't [ __ ] tell you enough
help them out throw him a few [ __ ]
bucks
fight big body odor [ __ ] corporate
america man and [ __ ] go for native
nativedeo.com
we thank the good folks uh at native for
sponsoring fat man beyond give it up for
the good folks at native ladies and
gentlemen
um all right we've gotten the
advertisements out of the way our
upfront chit chat uh this week ladies
and gentlemen uh is going to focus
on a budding young artist
new talent we always talking about
discovering new talent on this show well
this show has new talent on it that
discovered itself
this week and i don't mean like oh i'm
touching myself although
art is very masturbatory it's a whole
other conversation long story short
mark made a short this weekend he made
splinter short man
we did it what was the experience like
that you wanted to direct
by the time you were 50 you [ __ ] did
it in the first week of being 50 out of
yeah we had a discussion out in the in
the back with some of the good folks
that helped finance the the flick
through the kickstarter who were also
extras in it they were indeed um and god
there was so much setup i forgot the
point i was about to make
what was the really good point that i
was about to steal and then i was like
don't steal it give credit and then i
was so busy giving credit i forgot i
fell into a [ __ ] pothole and i can't
get out of it
um i i think you might have to smoke
what was it
first week of 50 the first week of 50.
new talent yeah i i i can't help you
with this one because i don't know what
are you doing whatsoever [ __ ]
discovering your body it's very
masturbatory i said mm-hmm
god damn it um it was gonna be a
beautiful point starter supporters who
were here and i yeah who were background
players in it it's gone
do you need to go back out and finish
that job i should i might be able to
trigger it the only way out of the
pothole is through the point is this
you're the the uh the the the baby
artist who went on the journey i'm the
guy who always interrupts i'm gonna put
the [ __ ] microphone down and you're
gonna tell all of us
a story about what it was like to do the
thing oh that's what it was oh [ __ ]
thank you i'm so glad the the the point
about you did it in the first week of
being 50 because i was like out back i
was like
you know you wanted to do it by the time
you're 50 how old he's like i've turned
one week god's 50.
and then who pointed it out
said
what's your name call it out
carol pointed out like well
technically he's 50 all year
and we were able to flip the [ __ ]
script like stoners
and be like oh my god you did it in the
first week of 50. you [ __ ]
overachiever
um so i'm going to arrest the mic
and let's all hear a story what was it
like
to direct your splinter short um
well i'll tell you kevin because you
asked so nicely
uh it was it was a little bit surreal
a lot surreal because the the process of
writing is so often a solitary one even
if you're in a writing room you know
where there's a couple of other people
and you're working on a thing together
like you at the end of the day it's you
and the keyboard and i've sort of
resigned myself to that for a while the
idea that that the art that i make will
eventually hopefully be seen by other
people and there will be a lot of people
who make it but the experience of my
direct connection to it is solitary and
then it goes off into the world and does
what it does
um
but the idea that
you know we we and by we i mean there
were like some 50 people on this set
um many of which i did not know before i
showed up
um because the way it tends to work is
you know i hire some sort of key people
some department heads and you know my
producers were collaborators and my
director photography you know was a very
big um part of this but like my director
of photography showed up with a crew
showed up with her camera crew and
showed up with the grips and electric
and showed up with those guys and who
i'd never met before and you know same
thing with makeup red our friend red did
was our you know hair and makeup lead
and so she brought a couple of people
and who i had never met before so it
becomes this weird mixture of meeting a
bunch of people and working intensely
closely with them for a very short
amount of time but very quickly
discovering that we all kind of
vibrating on the same wavelength and
i was crazy nervous because i had never
done it before and you know first timers
uh often nervous in most things
but the the philosophy that i was trying
to go by was act as if
act as if you've done this before act as
if you know what you're doing act as if
you've been here before
and uh and it kind of served me pretty
well because
the one thing that i knew that i knew
was the story
you know and and i knew what it was
supposed to do i knew what it was
supposed to achieve i knew the kind of
emotional feeling you're supposed to get
from it
even if i wasn't entirely clear about
how we were going to get there i sort of
knew what the goal posts were and so
just kind of finding the way and like
working with the crew and hitting a
rhythm in a stride
and you know i mentioned it online i did
a big thread about our dance parties
we would every
every time we ended a scene um or had to
like flip the lighting around oh
oh no i'm sorry something just fell down
uh you can't see that at home but only
we can see it here it's just for us
um
you know when you're making a movie did
you say somebody fell down no something
fell down it was like oh it's like
pretty [ __ ] casual like get a
hospital guy
hospital guy call the ambulance
you hospital guy go to the healing place
get the woohoo car you gotta get him out
of here
what the [ __ ] woo-woo car
oh my god i really lost the power of
english for a second
call the hospital guy back to you uh
so yeah the the a thing that i learned
from kevin and i'm not entirely sure
when i learned it but the idea that a
director on a set is a host
and that you know if you can get people
in a good mindset if you can keep them
sort of happy and engaged and
invigorated you'll get their best work
and so i took that idea to the next
level i put a little bluetooth speaker
in the pocket of my hoodie
and every time we would end a scene or
have to move lights or anything which
would buy us like 10 or 15 minutes
between shooting i would play a song
and at first the crew's like where the
[ __ ] is this music coming from and why
are we listening to music i don't
understand what's happening i'm supposed
to be working
and then normally on movie sets uh they
don't do that they like [ __ ] very quiet
and whatnot uh so that's why people were
reacting just to give a yeah a little
bit background yeah it's usually a bit
like a monastery where we're all just
like doing our thing
and then every now and again like is
that tupac yeah it's tupac
like is that poison
do i trust a big button a smile
yeah we do
and and then by the end of the show like
you know the crew members like you know
i'm from dc what do you got like all
right uh doing the butt yeah we're gonna
be doing the butt all night long sexy
sexy ow ain't nothing wrong if you do in
the butt all day long and and the the
feeling began to be joyous it began to
be we're all happy to be there and you
know 50 people who didn't know each
other by the end of it we're [ __ ]
hugging and crying and
maybe i was doing all the crying um
because i was a [ __ ] mess i was a
mess because like when you're starting
and it's going in the energy and you
start seeing things coming alive and and
it's it gets to be emotional in a way
that i was not prepared for but i was
ultimately not prepared for the last day
you know and it's again it's a four-day
shoot like it's not that long
but that last day
as we started like rapping out members
of the cast you know all right this is a
this is a picture app that's where they
say when it's the last
um time a person is working on the sets
the picture wrapped for moonblood good
everybody yay applause it's a picture of
patricia helfer yay applause
it's a it's a picture wrap for brooks
firestone who was the ten-year-old kid
who was playing sort of the center of
our of our story
yes trisha alfred yeah you had [ __ ]
six in there capric showed up to play i
put her in a cockpit and everything
wow
yeah
canada's own tricia alberta's own yeah
[ __ ] um that's cool you do battle
instead or your co-host for battlestar
galactica yeah yeah very sweet back to
you back to me
um and brooks the kid who's a the 10
year old kid who's sort of at the center
of the story his first ever thing his
first ever uh
scripted performance
and so he and i sort of had this whole
thing it's like it's both of our first
times brooks neither of us have done
this before like we're both kind of
learning as we go
and like he started to get a little
emboldened by the fact that he wasn't
alone and not being an expert at it and
i started to sort of like lean on him
and trust him a little bit because he
was like peter naturally gifted and so
when you wrapped him
it started to get like you know a little
touch and go but look don't look at me
the mask is hiding things i hope
and then when we got to the end and
our first ad the first ads job is to run
the set you know he's the sort of the
the the staff sergeant who keeps the
army going and he's the guy who keeps
the schedule makes sure that we're
making our days who makes sure that
everything is where it's supposed to be
who calls quiet on the set when people
still banging hammers in the background
we got to the last shot and it was like
mark do you want to call it i was like
man i can't i just can't he's like well
all right then i'll do it that is a wrap
on splinter and then i'm like
and then he stops and like everybody's
looking at me to say a thing
and and i just started crying
i just like you know give me a second
i'll pull it together i'll pull it
together and then just you know
thanked everybody for helping me make a
dream come true
in a way that that i hadn't anticipated
it ever happening you know the feeling
that i've been holding this dream since
i was a 20 year old kid who wanted to
like go to college and be some weird
mixture of spike lee and steven
spielberg and then 30 years later new
york spike lee wouldn't that be jordan
peele at the end of the day
i was trying to be my own thing but okay
sure he beat me to it
yeah
let's say jordan beale did the mark
i'm a grower not a shower
how
magical
was the experience
of watching
a production come together
like you've been on sets or whatever but
like your thing watching your vision
come to life and watching how everybody
does their part how it's really like
that story of stone soup where you know
one motherfucker's like
i could cure this town's hunger
everybody bring one ingredient to the
[ __ ] pot and i'll put in the magic
stone and [ __ ] the director brings the
magic stone i i would like to think
that's what i try to do i can't speak
for other directors i think michael
bay brings the shout out
the yelly but i like to bring the you
know the [ __ ] stone and everybody
brings their ingredient and then bam
suddenly you got a wicked stew and stuff
you
are the x factor the intangible the
one component
that you can't cast or
hire
you've got to bring something
that nobody else has and that everybody
wants for that four days or however long
they're in your life
all they want to do is get that [ __ ]
movie out of your head
out into the real world
what was it like yeah i mean it's it's
i would say that it's like a like hey
it's their job right they get paid to do
this thing and they do it all the time
but
we weren't paying them what they should
get
you know we were somewhat scrappy we
raised a lot of money but we also made a
big [ __ ] movie and so the fact that
people were willing to come to work for
less than they should get the less than
their worth
and still work as hard as they did
as well as they did for as long as they
did
was the most humbling thing
of just you guys believe and i don't
know why you believe um i i assume that
i have something to do with that because
i'm acting as if i know what the [ __ ] is
going on and that that's yeah sure but
the camera there that sounds a great
idea oh yeah no we'll sure we'll pull it
back and the lighting's awesome but can
we can you do like ten percent more or
ten percent less i got very george lucas
i got very faster more intense
slower less intense
um
that's what it means to be george lucas
that according to harrison ford that's
how i [ __ ] my wife
i'm gonna start calling that i'm like
i'm gonna give you the lucas tonight
faster and more intense
but it's like i'm over here i'm like oh
[ __ ]
george me not by my size do you
very nice
um
so it was it was a level of humility i
think you know in the face of talent
um and the the weird sort of we all just
want to believe in a dream
of hollywood and
if you can give them a dream to believe
in
then they'll do the impossible and if
you can keep believing that dream and
keep you know some sense of perspective
on it they'll they'll [ __ ] they'll
they'll do miracles for you
and that's phenomenal in a way that i've
never really appreciated before
it is it's magical how folks come
together doesn't it [ __ ]
like not to you know
disparage anyone else and i'm not naming
names but doesn't it baffle you
when you now [ __ ] hear stories about
directors who like [ __ ] yell or and
again i'm not like i was kidding about
michael bay i've never been one on sets
i don't know if he yells
but
having heard stories of directors who
are like
[ __ ] shouty or [ __ ] at their crew
or like everyone sucks and they're
getting it wrong and my vision
isn't it mind-bending that anyone would
[ __ ] act that way considering how
much
they how much the crew the cast everyone
[ __ ] gives
yeah i mean i i sort of feel and i
remember feeling this way in a couple of
writer writers rooms that i was in is
that you have to
you have to gamble as if every chip has
the same number on it
you know if you sit down at a blackjack
table there are there's the way to play
blackjack whether it's a five dollar
chip or a hundred dollar chip or a
thousand dollar chip you always split
aces and eights you always double down
on 11. like these are just things you do
when you're making a movie if it costs
fifty dollars or five fifty thousand
dollars or fifty million dollars
it still does the same things and you
can't let the pressure of that number
[ __ ] with you because i think that a lot
of that is insecurity i think a lot of
that is like i'm losing control and the
yelling is a way to reassert some sense
of control because it's so huge
but if you just play like the numbers
are the same
then like yeah all right [ __ ] it we're
making the thing guys like even if it's
a james bond movie like well i know
we're doing like nine countries and 200
million dollars and a [ __ ] ton of stunts
but
movies and movies a movie
until some [ __ ] lets their mask
slip
and then then mission impossible becomes
mission oh [ __ ] he won't stop yelling at
me
you know so i think that
that's a lot of that behavior is just
this semblance of i'm afraid i'm afraid
it's getting out of my hands i'm afraid
it's getting away from me i'm afraid
that they're going to know that i'm just
making this up as i go and i'm trying to
cover for that fear with aggression
you know or seclusion like i'm only
going to be on set when it's you know
when i'm ready to call cut or action or
whatever i'm going to hide in my trailer
and do whatever the [ __ ] i'm doing in my
trailer as opposed to like being a part
of it like it's a circus and you're the
ringleader and the ringleader's got to
be with the rest of the circus otherwise
the [ __ ] animals start doing [ __ ]
and the trapeze guys are blowing the
[ __ ] fire dudes and
did you shoot a porno
welcome to cirque du soleil everybody
this is how it goes winter he's going to
splint her with his dick
well you know well this doesn't go well
i've got a plan
um i am uh insanely uh proud of you i
expected uh nothing less though
uh that you would capture uh what you
wanted to get you're such an excellent
storyteller as we here even on this show
every week but
um i was in the back in our green room
with uh some of mark's guests tonight
who were
uh folks who
fired up i guess one of the kickstarter
categories that also allowed them to be
in it as well is that correct
um
and all of them
gave like a glowing
report card
of
mark's
not just mark's you know directing but
his deportment
as the director which is
something you rarely [ __ ] hear in
this business you know the directors get
a claim for like oh they're genius and
they shot this and oh yeah but
you know after they gave him his props
as a filmmaker they were very quick to
give him his props as the guy who was
inclusive
wasn't just like oh you [ __ ] came and
you stand there and do a thing he
engaged with them involved everybody and
stuff not just put him on screen but
like
kept them informed which is a big part
of the job
it's all about information that's a job
of answering questions essentially as
i'm sure you learned very quickly it's
like you just need to have that [ __ ]
answer when somebody asks you and all
they do is ask you questions all day
long and the director just has to be
able to be like yes of course it's red
no of course it's going to be 39 seconds
what no [ __ ] length not width like
[ __ ] like that
um so it's i had every confidence that
you would be able to you know do the job
itself but like it was delightful to
hear
how
like fun you treat it because it should
be a fun [ __ ] job like you get to
make pretend and like the stress of
you know carrying four days is is not a
bad amount of stress right amount of
stress for the first time out like where
you'll treat it with gravity but you're
not like you know my god now i've got
four more weeks of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
so good for you yeah you know i was
surrounded by i mean yes there were a
bunch of strangers who i got to know
relatively well but then there were
friends and family who were also there
and sort of came down to show some love
you know like my son was an extra on
that last day so he rolled out 17 year
old kid he's like buddy you're going to
be here for like eight hours you're cool
with that it's like yeah this will be
fun
and by the end of the day yeah this was
fun
um
my cousin my cousin richard like flew
himself from montreal
to come down and shoot behind the scenes
stills and porsche gallery of the stars
and you know the the stills for the
movie and he's a fancy ass fashion
photographer who's like yeah i'm gonna
carve out three days and 100 i'll be
there for you
like you guys have the same last name
yeah yeah so your name up there makes
like [ __ ] sense just fits the [ __ ] in
nepotism
down here everybody's like mark
bernardin
yeah now he's fancy that way but you
know he came in and he [ __ ] killed it
you know the the stuff that he shot is
gorgeous
and to have that sort of little cocoon
of familiarity and warmth and
and if everything seemed like it was
going shitty which it never really did
but there's always that moment when
you're like is this yeah is it red or is
it blue no it's going to be red let's
make it red
there was always somebody to sort of
lean to and say do we like this
my director photography was very much
that the script coordinator was very
much that do we have what we need yeah
all right moving on let's go
but it's it's feeling that level of
comfort to be able to make decisions
that that may or may not seem arbitrary
and to trust yourself
i mean i think any time you're making
art of any kind somebody is about
trusting your gut and saying i feel like
it's this and i can't explain why really
but i just feel it this way yeah and and
being able to to let that ride on
something as big as this or
the one thing that i learned that i was
super appreciative of yeah is i don't
know how directors do anything else
besides direct
and so
the level of appreciation i have for
like i remember you're making clerks
three and i'm just like texting you
about [ __ ] podcast dates and then you
would answer me and now i'm like why was
he answering me
because it was clerk's three
if i don't have it down by now what the
[ __ ] good am i at the job
because i was making the movie i was
answering your texts i was applying for
my next job and [ __ ] like that
and i was working quick stop selling
cigarettes at the same time i was
multitasking yeah like just everything
else in my life just went fell by the
wayside while i was doing that before it
is as it should be for like the first
time because and not because it's like
it demands all the concentration of a
nuclear physicist no because it's like
you've dreamed about doing this your
whole [ __ ] life you should enjoy
every [ __ ] second you should be on
set
every [ __ ] second you should you know
be soaking it the [ __ ] up because
this has been a long time coming
so it makes sense that you didn't engage
with like anything else i was shocked
that you kept [ __ ] your social media
up the whole time
like you know you kept doing tweets and
instagram and i'm like
boy how does he [ __ ] man i as you're
like how does kevin
spend that many plates i was like why is
he spinning this many plates why is he
updating us on the regular but i
thrilled to the regular uh updates it
was fun to see like how joyous you were
you can see it in your post and how
appreciative uh you were for to have the
crew and the cast that you did it's
really sweet yeah i mean we we we
luckily we got we started every day at
eight o'clock and we were tail lights
they say
you want to see the taillights of the
crew driving away fast [ __ ]
dropping the lingo dropping the
lingo uh tail lights by 7 30 every day
oh very good under 12 hours yeah and so
the fact that i could be home
like icing my feet because i was on my
standing for all day every day
this is a [ __ ] marathon not a sprint
i got the comfiest nurse shoes on now
still that's one of my favorite parts of
the job like in the beginning
you know they'd give you a chair and i
would be like what the i don't i don't
like high director chairs it's
it's like being on a horse is too high
so i like the low director chair as
close to the center of gravity as
possible so for the first like 10 years
like i would sit in the chair and [ __ ]
and then a certain film i forget which
one it was but i realized that if you're
on your feet the whole day oddly enough
i think it was yoga hosers you get 10
000 steps just standing on set all day
long because you don't really stand
because you're like oh i'm over here oh
i'm over here i'm doing this and and i
i don't know if it's the same for you
but like um
when i
when i do when i direct i it's this i do
this a lot so i'll be sitting there
going like this where i'm just like all
right so we're going to do this and then
we're going to move over here and this
is the next thing we're doing so much so
that jeff anderson and clarks plays
clerks 3 plays randall randall makes a
movie and at one point we were shooting
a scene
and jeff was playing randall who was
being excited about the potential for
this movie he's making and he starts
going like this
and i was like you son of a [ __ ] um
that um
josh roush
liv his wife calls it kevin's impatient
dance but it's never out of a sense of
impatience because i've analyzed those
because people ask me they're like well
what music are you hearing in your head
when you dance and i was like i don't
really hear music all i'm hearing in my
head is i'm getting exactly what i want
in life i'm getting exactly what i want
in life and it's just enthusiasm because
i'm like oh my god how rare is this and
stuff did you
i mean you had a dance party and stuff
yes but there was also the like there's
a little bit of like
yes yeah they can't help it because
you're like
this is [ __ ] neat and you're like why
don't i do this all the time like it's
just it fits except i had wham in my
head
what were you singing
before you go go i don't know why and
you wanted to be spike lee somehow
you know the steven spielberg part now
makes more sense it's all coming
together
that is uh it was awesome and uh it was
i thank you for my part in it i was so
happy to be there as an actor in the
[ __ ] movie
uh you do have an outstanding cameo in
the movie i saw you did yeah somebody
said did jordan send it yeah
absolutely adorable
um it was uh very very cool man um i
can't wait to watch are you gonna cut it
yourself no
no i didn't trust myself for that
yeah look at you yeah yeah you know what
i mean [ __ ] first time out
yeah let me get a pro yeah hand it over
to somebody and you know you know and
then just they're going to give you what
you want yeah it's shocking if they were
like no i see it this way they cut like
[ __ ] uh like this
or something like that yeah why is it
four minutes long
we shot 19 minutes worth of movies how
is it black and white what'd you do with
the color did you not see the colors
that we shot
didn't like it
wait this is citizen kane
[Laughter]
did you just put another movie in here
um but yeah he's going to get work on it
after the holidays because i was like
listen dude don't break your balls
before christmas like have a holiday and
then in january i'm still stuck on the
editor taking over your [ __ ] movie
and turning it into citizen plane
[Laughter]
it was a dad joke but it was worth
stopping the show for no but your dad's
in the audience going well done fellow
father well done yes you've lost your
edge but uh the spoon is just as good
yes
[Laughter]
um well that's [ __ ] uh darling man to
watch a dude finally [ __ ] get what
he's always wanted and stuff and it's
probably the first of many you see
yourself doing it again i think so yeah
how could you not once you get a taste
for it you're like
how do you keep them down on the farm
once they've seen perry as they say like
one blade gets a little taste out of
human blood
it's a much better analogy for this show
um give it up for [ __ ] mr mark
bernard and he directed
he's a director now
as i
as i said to mark in the in the back
alley and my best paul servino when i
saw him you frosted your cherry
good fella style um while mark was uh
directing his movie i was uh doing
something uh i was uh
i was i i was not directing but i was
producing
the [ __ ] birthday event of a lifetime
i took my 76 year old mother on her
birthday
my mother grace
to graceland in memphis tennessee
my mother has always been a big fan of
elvis and uh you know red
our aforementioned friend red who did
the hair and makeup the hair makeup on
mark's movie
um
was like take your mom to graceland she
wants to go to graceland and i was like
what the [ __ ] like how did you say
my mom she knows my mom she should chest
with my mom my mom gets to know
[ __ ] she won't let them out of
their
life you know and say so she
was talking to her and she's like she
she wants to go to graceland i was like
oh she surely she would have mentioned
that bun now i'm sure she went to
graceland i was like ma you ever go to
graceland she's like no
and i was like do you want to go and
she's like oh i've always wanted to go
to graceland and i was like oh my god i
can [ __ ] make this happen and [ __ ]
so we wound up going on her birthday
weekend and
like you want to talk about
giving like
mom the perfect gift
like i couldn't
fair enough carry on i could i
like literally couldn't have given i
could have
it was like giving her the equivalent of
a vibrator she was just like oh
it made her feel so [ __ ] young and
i guess comey is what i'm getting at
like she
oh my god like i you should see how
[ __ ] i put up his pictures on
instagram she's
bright like a [ __ ] teenager like it
was weird to see my mother's fandom
come out you know like i've spent my
life being a fanboy of things and she
like had to sit there through all of
them like oh he loves snoopy now he
loves batman now he loves star wars now
he loves bullwinkle now he loves [ __ ]
you know gretzky what the [ __ ] like
she's seen me go through so many [ __ ]
like fandoms and you know my mother has
always appreciated elvis listen to his
albums and stuff but i never really knew
you know she was a grown-ass woman
married by the time i met her i was the
third kid and [ __ ] so you know elvis was
like oh i listened to old elvis records
and whatnot it was mom music to me and
you know she the way she liked elvis was
the way she liked olivia newton john but
based on what i saw at [ __ ] graceland
this weekend oh no oh my god [ __ ]
if i was not sharing a [ __ ] hotel
room with my mother
and she was alone it would have been a
little less conversation a little more
action my friend she would have been
just [ __ ] rubbing herself on the
furniture she loved [ __ ] graceland
so so much man she knew [ __ ] as we
pulled into it she's like this is this
that is that she was touching things and
you're not supposed to touch [ __ ] but
they let her because she's an old lady i
guess or whatever
what are you gonna do it was so lovely
she was so happy dude it was like porn
for mothers like
just puts a smile on her face so
gratifying [ __ ] satisfying and stuff
and so delightful for me to see her
fan out and just be that that person
something she's seen me do like a
zillion times over the course of my
lifetime now
i go to graceland for mom right like
this is all about mom and mom so [ __ ]
happy and crying on the way home and
[ __ ] like that
i went as a person that's like look i
understand elvis's cultural significance
and stuff like that but my
crossover with elvis is like oh that's
my my mom loves elvis and then ernie who
runs smog castle he [ __ ] loves elvis
he went to graceland and [ __ ] like that
which always baffled me because i'm like
what the [ __ ] like you're 50 you know
and he's like that that doesn't sound
right to you a 50 year old that likes
elvis and i'm like i want to take care
of business in a flash too i guess so
man so like you know i always respected
him and stuff but they're in his place
of pop culture but
like when i first got there
i was shocked by the amount of [ __ ]
people that still
deeply deeply deeply give a [ __ ] about
this man and know everything about him
like
there were people who weren't tour
guides who were tour guiding me
around the place and giving me [ __ ]
factoids and information that blew my
hair back
do you know him like i think of him as a
you know [ __ ] rock star right the
first rock star
but i'm walking around like they've got
like the main house but they also built
this pavilion across the way where you
see all his costumes and and there's all
these exhibits and [ __ ] like elvis in
the army and elvis in the movies and
stuff and you're seeing all these movie
posters and whatnot
the man made
31 motion pictures in the span of
like 10 years
to be fair
none of them are good doesn't matter
it doesn't matter that's like that's
like a [ __ ] tyler perry level of
output
[Laughter]
um what about as good i asked nate
before we went uh i said nate look up
tom hanks
uh tom cruise and who's the oh will
smith to see like how many movies each
one of those cats have made what do we
get for tom cruise
has been in 50 [ __ ] movies
uh depends on who you ask but yeah at
least 50 according to
imdb that's his like 100 credits it's
50. he's he's been working since like 81
and 10. i guess there have been like 28
mission impossibles as well
um all right mission it turns out is
like actually really possible yeah
mission very possible
mission possibly going to happen again
if you keep buying this [ __ ] we did it
you guys like you do everything the next
one will smith according to imdb has 77
or if you ask google is 60.
77
these guys make elvis look like a chump
and then uh well you want to know what's
in the tom hanks bank yeah
95 according to imdb or google says
116.
wow
wow
well there goes my whole [ __ ] point
about like i'm still impressed 31 movies
in a very short span of his life for a
dude who's not an actor yeah it's crazy
he's as much a movie star to a lot of
people as he's a rock star this
[ __ ] went in the army
like could you imagine
any pop star going into the army at the
height of their career giving up two
years to go be in the army
like it's just crazy that that happened
he's the king yes i guess he my mom we
were you know they got the archives
because they i guess like the presley
family are hoarders and they saved
literally
[ __ ] everything everything from like
you know here's the tv that he shot with
a gun which you could [ __ ] see it's
on display so like here's the [ __ ]
deed to the graceland uh and here's the
check the cancel check for a thousand
bucks here's the check for the gates
that they put up they like literally
[ __ ] save everything instead do they
have his deputy badge yeah which one
they had a [ __ ] like a board full of
100 he was a big badge fiend he liked to
collect badges honorary badges so we had
a bunch of them that was like when you
went into the house on the tour they
were like you know for christmas we
bring out this very special item you're
going to touch an item that elvis
touched and it's like one of the many
badges that he he was gifted and stuff
they made my mom put on like white glo
everybody they're like you have to put
on white gloves and [ __ ] like that to
touch it and so in the beginning of the
tour i was like come on like come on
white gloves and [ __ ] you know i looking
at the whole thing always from the
perspective of like you know i i have a
tourist trap of my own you know jay and
bob's secret stash where i sell
knickknacks and souvenirs and [ __ ] like
that so like i know the game like this
is great you know my mom's like we can't
spend this money on souvenirs i was like
ma for all the years people have come
into my store from around the world and
[ __ ] bought jane's on bob trinkets i
can get you elvis [ __ ] shirts while
we're at graceland like you know like
let's do this so
i went in very you know like this is for
her and
you know
it'll be interesting because it's nice
to see how a business operates and this
is a one of america's most premier
tourist attractions even still a show
like that you bought a jumpsuit didn't
you i fell in love with elvis
but i by the end of it i understood like
oh my god like the magic of this guy and
stuff like that it's [ __ ] crazy how
accomplished he was and he did it in the
20-year span
of life that's it just 20 years like
and then the factoids that you're given
like i met this guy who's got like an
elvis youtube channel
and he was telling me because i was like
you know
i said i know he wore capes because he
loved
captain marvel he goes that's absolutely
right he's going elvis was a big comic
book fan he's going there's a clip
playing right there where he's receiving
one of the only awards he ever showed up
to receive in person from the memphis
jaycees and stuff and he talks
specifically about reading comic books
and seeing himself as the hero he's
going so taking care of business the
lightning bolt taking care of business
in a flash he's gone the lightning bolt
was taken from captain marvel from
shazam his pompadour
was taken from captain marvel from
shazam so when he got into his costume
wearing era because and i found this
[ __ ] fascinating performers of the
day male performers generally wore just
tuxedos or suits and that's it he's the
first guy that gave a [ __ ] about what he
wear where he was like you know what i'm
going to wear like flared collars which
no man had ever worn a high collar until
this guy wore a high collar and he only
got away with it because he was
considered so [ __ ] pretty like a
woman that they're like we'll let it go
and everyone all guys started wearing
like high collars like this dude was
like a fashion trendsetter and also like
was i'm not gonna say he dressed
androgynously but he he started doing
something that most women most female
performers were associated with giving a
[ __ ] about outfits the dude had a series
of outfits he'd wear one and just not
wear it again and [ __ ] like that he
became like a fashion
template so not only is it like this
rock star [ __ ] icon and [ __ ] but he's
a fashion icon he's a movie star um my
mom as we went through the archives she
was like i had that i had that they had
merchandise on display like they this
guy was star wars in 1955 they had
[ __ ] toys my mom was like i had that
45 record case the 40 she's like i had
all my elvis records and she's like i
can't believe she rolled a tear seeing
this [ __ ] item and i looked at all
the merchandise going like oh my even
from an early age this was the first one
this was the one where they were like we
can sell pencil cases off this guy like
we could literally put his face on
[ __ ] anything and it'll [ __ ] sell
he became this incredible industry but i
was very like impressed by the whole
organization i was put together the
thing i fell down the rabbit hole on
was like his daughter the family aspect
because when you go there
there's this weird feeling of like oh
this is somebody's house and it's
literally frozen in time essentially the
moment he died they sealed everything up
and it's all still there everything is
the way he left it everything in the
house is all of his [ __ ]
everything is like they bring you to the
kitchen i found this mind blown it's one
of my favorite parts of the tour they
bring you through the kitchen and they
go you see that microwave over there
that's the first microwave in the city
of memphis ever
and that's got trivia where i'm like
you're getting me hard tell me the story
how did this [ __ ] happen the first
ever like what a cool [ __ ] first and
they're like well elvis you see was a
huge technology buff he had to have the
latest of everything and whatnot so
elvis paid 6500
for this microwave the most expensive
[ __ ] microwave ever sold because it
was one of the first models but he had
it and [ __ ] i was blown away by that i
was just like oh what like thank god
somebody was like save the microwave
someone will appreciate it i don't know
if anyone ever on the tour ever
appreciated but i was like that was
worth 190 dollars right there
because you're telling a formerly fat
person about the first food device in
this whole [ __ ] state
yes please just a trivia buff like
that's kind of you know what kind of
currency that is whipping that out at a
party you're like you know who had the
first [ __ ] microwave in memphis ever
what [ __ ] party are you going to
when anybody would give a [ __ ] about the
providence of memphis microwaves one
where they'd be like uh elvis and i'd be
like yeah how'd you figure that out
do you know what he paid for it they're
like i don't know 10 grand i'm like well
6 500 but your story's better right
oh i was so [ __ ] blown away but the
family aspect of it i found like kind of
touching because you know a certain
point you are in somebody's house
like it feels weird and when they're not
home like it feels just strange then you
get out to like the garden and the
meditation garden is where he's buried
and he's buried next to his mom his mama
he's buried next to his dad his grandma
and [ __ ] there's a marker for his twin
stillborn twin but the body's not there
they said the body was a shoebox and an
unmarked grave in tupelo and they've
never been able to find it so there's
just a marker there but there's
something that like killed me is
incredibly poignant like i you know
i walked away
like a much bigger fan of elvis than i
ever was but i became i fell down the
rap you know you fall into like the
subject assumption you're like i want to
read everything about this the rabbit
hole i fell down was lisa marie presley
because i've read a story about when
they were laying him out elvis because
she was there the night he died and
stuff she's nine when he dies
they lay them out and he's in a white
suit and a blue shirt
and she goes to the funeral director
she goes can i give this to my daddy and
it's a bracelet a little bracelet
and you know funeral director is
normally like no [ __ ] jewelry you
know on the bodies and [ __ ] but he's
like am i gonna tell her no so
he's like yeah absolutely and she's like
can you do it and he brings her up to
the to the casket and he realizes she
like can't interact with her dead father
so she's not looking at the body and
stuff but she's holding out the bracelet
and he's like where do you want it and
she points to her own wrist where she
wants it on him and so he goes in gently
lifts up you know the dude's arm because
he's embalmed at this point and stuff
and puts the bracelet on him and puts it
back down and he walks her back to her
mom
and he said like that right before he
handed off to priscilla she was like
will it be there forever
and he was like yeah it's going to be
there forever and she was like okay
and pretty naturally calm went back to
her [ __ ] mother this poor kid
surrounded by [ __ ] death she loses
her dad at age nine her grandfather dies
like two [ __ ] years later then her
aunt or uncle dies then she has like a
friend commits suicide at a young age
she loses two friends in a car accident
like she's just [ __ ] like surrounded
by death and so there's a song like that
she put out an album like years and
years ago i think 2003 2004
um called uh to whom it made concern i
think it was and it had a big single on
it i don't know if anyone remembers but
it's called lights out and it was a song
that actually referenced her heritage
and stuff and there's a chorus to the
song
that goes
someone turned the lights out down in
memphis that's where my family's buried
and gone last time i was there i noticed
a space left next to them there in
memphis in the damn back lawn she's
literally talking about where her
[ __ ] relatives are buried and the
idea is that as she stands there looking
at them she's like there's where i'm
going to [ __ ] be how strange you know
what i'm saying like to be like oh my
god i'm part of this massive legacy and
i'm going to wind up right here so i
always [ __ ] really thought that song
was kind of powerful and really cool and
[ __ ]
i know she didn't want to lead with it
because it's very elvis oriented but
it's a [ __ ] to borrow a term from
kids which they probably don't say
anymore [ __ ] tunes slapped so i
always really really liked it and so
when my when we were one of the exhibits
was about lisa marie and my mom was
something to ask me about like she did
an album and that's what triggered all
this i was like yeah man i bought that
album years ago and [ __ ] i had a [ __ ]
really good song on [ __ ] played it for
my mom instead and i was playing it
like i got really emotional because
in her life too she's got kids right
like she's got a daughter riley who's an
actress she was in the lodge and she was
a mad max and riley keough riley keough
um and she's got and riley has had a
brother named benjamin who two years ago
passed away took his own life and stuff
and
on the tour
opposite elvis
is the is his grave the boy's grave his
grandson
and i have been obsessed like i [ __ ]
can't listen to the song without getting
emotional and stuff with the idea that
like
she sang about that spot and it it was
filled by like somebody so [ __ ]
deeply close to her and stuff oh my god
so
tragic um uh circumstances like
surrounding this poor girl's life and
she still like endeavors and struggles
on so it's weird man i fell down like a
deep [ __ ] hole and stuff and i was
like
me and my mom were like up trading elvis
stories all night long talking about how
impressed we were with this guy's
[ __ ] life at one point she was like
this is just like you know what you have
with the jay and son bob secret stash
and quick stop except elvis was way more
famous than you'll ever be
you know mom just puts it right on
[ __ ] front street and stuff like that
mom was great aside from like the trip
which she loved every second up and she
gets around slowly now she's losing her
the ability to walk and stuff so
everything had to be just you had to
build in more time to do [ __ ]
like at one point like it was midnight
one of the nights and i was like you
know i'm like i'm gonna go to walmart uh
to grab some [ __ ] snacks and she was
like well i'll go with you and i was
like oh right on let's [ __ ] go to
walmart so we went to like walmart at
like midnight around midnight
in memphis and had a [ __ ] like blast
like just an absolute [ __ ] blast man
because she can get one of them electric
carts
which is [ __ ] dope man like she goes
she speed down aisles and [ __ ] like that
um and you know i the way i shop is like
we were gonna be driving to nashville
the next day to catch a flight so i was
like we'll get snacks for the whole you
know tonight to sit around [ __ ] and
then we'll have snacks the whole [ __ ]
ride there and stuff and you know she
loves chocolate so i was getting her all
the [ __ ] like
hershey's and [ __ ] like that she loves
really like name brand like store brand
chocolate and chocolate fan i mean or
hershey's and [ __ ] like that like but
you know your good old standard american
chocolate one that but she knows
schnapps she'll take godiva and [ __ ]
like that but like it don't matter
she'll take a godiva yeah yeah gleefully
and whatnot so we were getting a bunch
of snacks um and and having a [ __ ]
blast and she's like
you know just
she's like here she's going
she's like i've never had one of these i
was like let's get it she's like we'll
never be able to take it on the plane i
was like so we leave like food behind
like somebody will [ __ ] eat it it's
packaged like don't worry about that
like just let's try it out like [ __ ] you
you're 70 [ __ ] six what are you
waiting for man like [ __ ] if you want
to try a strawberry cream oatmeal try
the [ __ ] thing man
i'll get you a whole box and [ __ ] and
she wound up packing them in her [ __ ]
luggage to take back to florida
something you can easily get at any
goddamn grocery store so
i had a blast at [ __ ] walmart and
then i posted pictures on instagram i
was like hey man [ __ ] like went to
memphis mom saw graceland and then got a
slew of [ __ ] people in the comments
going that is the most dangerous part of
memphis
and that is the most dangerous walmart
then you took your mother to it and [ __ ]
and in retrospect i guess it was kind of
like you know unsettling that but i was
like who who comes to walmart and how
could i be judgey i was at walmart at
midnight so i was like i guess everybody
goes to walmart at midnight you know
like maybe there's nothing to do in
memphis this is doesn't exist i'm like
yeah i guess everyone goes to walmart
and [ __ ] but it was [ __ ] packed and
[ __ ] and i would have been an easy mark
man because i had like a crippled lady
with me and [ __ ] they could have knocked
her down i would have been like here
take it all you know but but we
we i think maybe because i had a
crippled mother with me
people involved with me yeah they were
like you know what [ __ ] too easy let
them go
but it was what an adventure man enjoy
the [ __ ] out of it your visit to grace
lane was far different from my visit to
graceland why what'd you do i mean i
went when i was like 27 years old or so
i was driving cross-country and we're
like [ __ ] let's go to graceland
we were there for like 45 minutes like
he stole all this from little richard
and then left
[ __ ] your house king
i was the guy i went in as too i was a
real like well i mean like i get it he's
a singer but like you know he didn't
write a lot of these songs i respect
singer-songwriters and then like you
really listen to his [ __ ] and like any
good actor performer he can take
material that he didn't write and make
it feel like it comes out of his
[ __ ] heart and soul
i just get it now in a way like it's not
like i never got i just never really
thought about it but now i like really
[ __ ] get it but i'm full of [ __ ]
annoying elvis factoids um i can't wait
for the next rest of my life yeah oh
get ready 2022 is on elvis podcast and
[ __ ] my wife is like oh it's going to be
[ __ ] a lot of elvis for the next week
isn't it i was like i know a lot right
now
um graceland
he did not name it graceland no he
bought it and it was already called
graceland is that [ __ ] up didn't you
just imagine he named it graceland i
would have thought and then you'd be
like well why would he name it graceland
it's not like his mom's name was grace
his mom's name was gladys so wouldn't he
name it gladys land
so there was really no reason to think
that he did name it graceland and he
didn't it was a state called graceland
before he bought it had 100 acres he
bought the house and 14 acres or
something and kept the the name
and you know put up those new gates and
[ __ ] and bam um crazy man
uh well i'm glad
that you had that kind of pop cultural
epiphany i did
it was nice yeah i mean i'm i'm
i i feel
jealous in a weird way
of your the ability to deep dive in a
thing that nobody's deep dived in for a
while
it's like did you guys hear about elvis
presley
have you heard the good news about the
king of rock and roll i am i'm like a
newborn christian man like born again
and newborn born again christian [ __ ]
where i'm like let me [ __ ] sell you
on jesus they're like yeah i've i've got
a he's on a magnet on my fridge i'm good
have you heard of elvis elvis presley no
no yeah and i got it not costello right
yeah no presley you're talking about
yeah i guess it's not really a hot take
i uh come to things
sometimes i come to things late in life
kids look it ain't [ __ ] direct in my
first short but i had a good time at
[ __ ] graceland yes no i appreciate it
it was really more about my mom yes it
very much was and tourism is delightful
i got a lot out of it as well um
but yeah
man [ __ ]
what an impressive life
like
200 gold records or some such [ __ ]
there's a wall i took a photo of my mom
in front of the wall i had to literally
lay down on the ground
to get all of the gold records in they
just got him stacked up on this giant
[ __ ] wall it was really really
impressive and [ __ ]
the house itself though not to be judgey
not very big
like you could fit i'm not and i'm not
being braggy but you can fit about four
of them into my house but somebody
pointed out on tour no i'm not i'm not
humble bragging but
but somebody when if you see the house
you would understand what i mean it's
not
you know you think graceland a mansion
you get in there's a hallway and there's
right away staircase very thin hallway
here and there's a living room a living
room and a kitchen and then it used to
be a back porch then closed it and that
became the jungle room upstairs there's
you can't go upstairs uh there's his
bedroom lisa marie's bedroom there's a
bathroom and that's it so it's not
[ __ ] huge a lot of grounds and [ __ ]
like they got horses and whatnot but the
house itself is not that big and
somebody pointed out it was built in
1940 this was huge for 1940 and i was
like why were people little then like
i don't get it because the ceilings
aren't that high at all like it feels
like you could fall off the roof and be
okay
like that i was really kind of taken
aback by did you try not at all
um but they won't let you in near that
second floor little on the roof
did you ever try to do that like jump
off like a roof like an awning or
something i think i think at
tonya stefan's house we jumped off her
roof into her pool once
did you
yeah i thought i could make a parachute
out of garbage bags
how old
seven
all right excusable i thought you were
gonna be like 17. yeah 32
no and yes i jumped off like this awning
over my driveway and uh
it didn't slow me down at all i thought
there'd be more you were wildly coyote i
was 400 percent like
right like we're gonna get there's gonna
catch and then i'll just kind of like
hover down to the ground like a [ __ ]
no
no i just hit the garbage cans like hard
um
what'd you learn charlie brown
gravity yeah
that's a rule right law maybe i don't
know some [ __ ] laws
um i just realized i'm still wearing my
coat and i wanted to wear that so i
could tell this story so i was traveling
uh with my mother and i was in the
airport and we were going to orlando
yes i think going to orlando
and um
waiting for a flight from nashville to
orlando
and a lady walks past me and she goes um
this is exactly how i'm dressed
she goes
nice robe
i know where you're going
and it was so [ __ ] cryptic
i was like to hell like what the
mom
like i was so scared
and i was trying to piece it together
but first i was i turned to my mother
and i go does this coat look like i'm
wearing a bathrobe and she goes no it
looks like a coat i was like that lady
called it a robe and she goes wheel me
over to that lady
and i was like i ain't letting you start
an old lady fight in the airport and
[ __ ] like that it was just weird and i
was sitting and going what the [ __ ]
could it mean then when we landed in
orlando um i was waiting uh with my mom
at the curbside somebody was picking her
up so then i had to get on a flight to
come back here
and uh the lady came by
and she stops me and goes
i thought you were wearing a robe
and going to the harry potter land
she's going but now i see it's not
really a robe and i was like ma did you
[ __ ] talk to that lady
at one point but she must have thought
about like after she said something to
me she must have walked away and maybe
said to her husband like i said to that
man nice robe and he was like what are
you [ __ ] high that's
clearly a coat man like i thought it was
a robe because you're also wearing
shorts which is a weird thing but
okay it's true i didn't fight her i
wasn't like madame i'm offended you know
i was like that's that's the nicest
thing anyone said about my outfit in a
long time like this was a brook's
brother's robe i'll have you know if she
was one step away from you look like a
hobbit young man
um all right enough about our lives
shall we die
oh hey give it up for banff
ladies and gentlemen jc's in the house
what do you got for us banff man i i was
just gonna say at least she didn't point
at you and go hufflepuff
oh [ __ ]
um
but but also with all the elvis talk yes
austin butler one of the stars of yoga
hosers is playing elvis yes that's true
one of the
uh austin who was in yoga hosers um
who's such a [ __ ] committed actor
like oh my god he went full canadian on
that movie nobody else tried for an
accent not even the girls but he [ __ ]
went for it he's like is this is this
sound convincing and i was like jesus
christ austin i was like i read the
script don't treat it that seriously but
he did man he's like all in as an actor
and [ __ ] so he played uh tex i think in
once upon a time in hollywood um they
got cast in baz lorman's [ __ ] elvis
movie which they put out a tiny teaser
for like a couple weeks ago where you
see a few shots of them as elvis but um
i was always looking forward to that
based on the fact that hey i love bass
lorem and b i love austin butler um and
c you know it felt like it was going to
be a big movie but now with my newfound
appreciation for elvis i'm gonna be
don't see the movie with me because the
whole movie i'll be leaning over be like
that part's not true
and then i'll probably provide the real
information but yeah i can't wait to see
that flick that was delayed by that was
the movie where tom hanks plays colonel
tom parker and he got coveted on that
[ __ ] movie right
oh right yeah that was the beginning of
the the the hanks wilson line that's
true where we didn't care about covet
and then tom hanks got it and then we
were like oh [ __ ] cove is real yeah it
might take america's tom hanks
if it could happen a gump it can happen
to all of us
um yeah man i look forward to that movie
in a big bad way
so uh so yeah that was about an hour
on uh elvis there's a delightful person
that after the every episode
does the times with little like uh urls
to them on when we talk about things in
the show so it'll say like you know
[ __ ] native ad
4.4 minutes 23 seconds
then it'll start mark director talk
half hour
then it'll be like
kevin elvis talk an interminable
let me like kevin elvis question mark
then there'll be like news finally or
something like that
um so yeah we're pretty deep into the
show but what the [ __ ] it's the last
show of the year ladies and gentlemen
you'll forgive us for going long tonight
bam
bamf man is back he's making the show
even longer what do you got for us man
for all the people in chat who are like
they're still talking about elvis and
all the future people pretend when kevin
says elvis he's talking about weed
yes and the whole story that's true the
last time i got this excited about a
subject it was weeds so i'm yeah i'm
smoking elvis right now um we're we're
done with [ __ ] elvis but you know for
a show about fandom i would hope you'd
be a little more tolerant
[ __ ] him and john wayne
[Laughter]
um
all right shall we dive into the news
that's all they give a [ __ ] about we'll
give you your goddamn news we totally
can uh mark bernard used to do the news
he's a [ __ ] director now no time for
news but it didn't anyway but he did it
anyway give it up for mark he brought
you the news
[Applause]
i know i'm over my limit but can i get
another one of these
i'm going hard on the water tonight
can i get another wakanda forever
get him drunk director drunk
action
[Laughter]
thank you um okay what do you got for us
um well i think the last time we were
here last time we gathered together we
gave some thoughts on cowboy bebop
um what do you guys know something i
don't know about what happened to cowboy
bebop
it's like you guys might have read the
news before i get to read the news
uh
so yeah cowboy bebop uh was cancelled
after its very first season
i mean that was awfully
fast and made me scared for masters of
the universe i'm like man they [ __ ]
they gave it one season
they do that well
uh
yeah i've known that i would have done a
different storyline maybe um
yeah i don't know what's going to be the
story there but i i was i was kind of
surprised that
one and done it seemed like an expensive
show i guess maybe that has something to
do with it according to deadline uh the
live action taken the anime classic was
met with mixed reviews by critics and
fans of the original and the series also
didn't make a lasting impression in the
streamer's top 10 rankings
because of how expensive cowboy bebop
was given it's filming in new zealand
and the like nine month break they took
when john cho broke his arm or his
collar bone i think doing his stuff like
not how long like somewhere between
eight and nine months
just down because of his injury and his
rehab that'll hurt um
the viewership borrowed had to clear in
order to secure renewal was higher which
would explain why the cancellation was
swifter than usual for netflix which
traditionally waits at least a full 28
day to get their audience data before
making pick-up decisions and it only
premiered on november 19th
yeah that was uh rather accelerated
it was um
what is that
banff
it's the bubbles the eggs let's turn it
i mean
how about it's battling against a bottle
yeah let's
yeah just unplug it
yeah look at that
yeah it's the sound of your life again
well it was sounding like my wife in bed
at night at three in the morning and
[ __ ] just
what are you doing ink nothing go to bed
turn the channel on the tv the remote's
real loud
[ __ ] going back to
bed are you sanding a table
[Laughter]
um all right yeah so no more cowboy
bebop boys and girls um well [ __ ] i hope
we're not doing a story similar to this
one day about our very own
masters of the universe somebody brought
this box whose box is this who brought
this cool ass box
they sent that as a like hey watch the
show
[ __ ] i wish they would have sent me
one i'm very very cool yeah uh
nothing but nice things being said about
nice too at least in uh season two at
least in my twitter feed i hate saying
that because anytime i do say that then
a bunch of people show up in my twitter
feed to be like [ __ ] we're still
here [ __ ] you
i understand that saying the whole
[ __ ] world but i'm saying like mostly
i see the next we were just taking a
break for lunch yes
we were we were [ __ ] busy with gay
superman we're back
but uh
i i you know fingers crossed for season
two knock on wood not come wood uh but
let's uh pour one out for kevin
cowboy
did they have an open-ended uh
season finale um yeah i think they were
definitely planning on more story um
because there was more story to be told
but
the best laid plans
what is there there was a there was a
saying that i was fond of on the set
which is everybody's got a plan until
they get punched in the face
um
that's what like muhammad ali used to
say like everybody's got a plan in the
ring until they get punched in the face
and then all your plans go out out of
the [ __ ] wayside because now you're
in a fight fair enough um no plan
survives a contact with the enemy and so
they had a plan
that was a [ __ ] deep enough quote
make me fall down a muhammad ali hole
i'll tell you right now man i'm like
that's profound that's profound um but
yeah they had a plan but
no plans are out of contact with the
audience and the audience was not there
and so sadly it was the end of the road
um see you space cowboy
that's
[Laughter]
um all right
yeah good news though is we got renewed
i have different good news oh [ __ ] sorry
uh charlie cox has officially officially
officially
been recognized and named as the mcu's
daredevil yeah give it up for
charlie cox being real finally
now foggy declared that he is the mcu's
daredevil he did and how and when
they'll use him they'll come to see but
he says he's the daredevil now whether
or not it is the like listen you guys
are going to see this [ __ ] spider-man
movie in a week i might as well say
or not
and he's well we've seen the photo he's
definitely in the movie right so and you
know no spoilers i haven't seen it yet
don't know what it's about what
spider-man no but we get to see it
thursday well
technically everybody does because it
opens on thursday
that's why i said we
very nice
um but yes so that that ends any
speculation as to what would happen
there and again
hawkeye seems to be leading us towards
getting to see kingpin yes and so
especially after uh last week's episode
so it seems although last week's episode
was like holy [ __ ] they [ __ ] they
spent a little money on the kid who from
the black widow movie the [ __ ] uh
florence
yeah
um she came in at the end of the show
her dive off the top of the building was
[ __ ] dope
like where she did the threw down the
[ __ ] cable did the run turn around
and [ __ ] looked at her she where she
dove i don't know [ __ ] like that but at
one point you literally were seeing
hawkeye two hawkeyes
versus
echo and a black widow
i liked when hawkeye was like don't you
understand how serious this is someone
hired a black widow
that was dope i liked if this was the
episode where i liked uh jeremy renner a
lot
more than i had uh liked in previous not
like i didn't like him in the first few
episodes but they gave him a real good
scene where he talked about like you
know i was a weapon
that they just used you know the good
people used on the right people and
stuff my favorite scene so far i think
it's in episode three
where his hearing aid is busted yes and
his son calls and at first he doesn't
know it's a son and then kate has to
translate for him
it broke my heart like
because it's
the thing they're playing with is the
tonnage of this guy's life and how it
weighs on him and we can't escape it no
matter how much he wants to and the
feeling that
he would just love to be able to have a
conversation with his kid or be home for
a movie night or be home like dad it's
okay if you don't make it over christmas
just like oh my god look at the [ __ ] huh
it's his [ __ ] fault he shouldn't
[ __ ] spoilers put on the ronin suit
and gone on [ __ ] with the underworld
now he's got to pay the [ __ ] price
i mean i read comic books that's justice
that's
that's karma biting you in the ass yeah
but yeah that that sort of stuff you
know it's it's a small scene it is not
plot at all it is just here's who this
guy is and here's the price he's paying
for what he's doing and even though the
stakes are small in that it's not saving
the world from a galactic beast
it's
the stakes are actually really really
[ __ ] high which is to be able to be
the father he's never been able to be
before and now [ __ ] is getting in the
way
um well
well uh insightful uh take mark uh i
feel uh the kid continues to be the
standout hailey stanfield
i'll watch a bunch of kate bishop [ __ ]
um
somebody i saw
online was theorizing that they may be
related they may have her related to
the julia louise dreyfus character
the contessa
i've read a pretty convincing theory
that i was like wow i guess that could
be based on the presence of menorahs and
uh what is the box they put on the side
of the door azusa a mezuzah um which
ties into possibly the contessa
character you know they're always
playing
deep cuts with these shows
um kingpin looks like could because
these could be the only two jewish
characters in the embassy yeah they're
like so they must be related we better
put them together until ben grimm shows
up that and kitty pride until ben grimm
shows up well done
um yeah it continues to be a charming
little [ __ ] show man that dude's
definitely the swordsman
um but it looks like kingpin may show up
this next episode uh what's as [ __ ] uh
vincent d'onofrio been
been making very obvious tweets on the
subject
it seems as if like if you get to be a
certain age like you don't give a [ __ ]
about marvel's security or whatever it's
like
what are you gonna do i'm vincent to
[ __ ] not for you
uh yeah i don't know cause he's still
being guarded man i think everybody's
scared of [ __ ] kevin foggy nobody
wants to get kicked out of the marvel
party and [ __ ] especially for something
as lame as like i couldn't keep my
[ __ ] mouth shut
like if you do you deserve to be tossed
out of [ __ ] paradise that's like
biting the apple or whatever the [ __ ]
and i hate to take it biblical but let
me take it back to elvis and put it this
way
internet's like move the [ __ ] on just
when you thought you were out he pulled
you back in
um right on yeah um
i guess we sidebarred into a [ __ ]
hawkeye review we did which is totally
fine that's how the show works we
sidebarred the [ __ ] into an elvis review
yeah it's true have you guys have you
heard about the elvis that's true have
you heard the good news yeah
um there's a boy born in tupelo and
moved to memphis
he was born in the ghetto
[Music]
in the ghetto
that's 70s elvis there's an elvis for
all seasons man
[Laughter]
my favorite elvis was uh
like uh belt elvis
when he started putting on the [ __ ]
jumpsuits and then the fatter he got the
wider the belt got yeah so like the
belts were up ultimately like below his
neck
he was like a wrestler
who never wrestled and it just
yeah most of his career
the dude was like the pencil thin
had a real he's six feet tall real thin
waist
he was fat elvis for only about a year
but there are so many pictures of him as
fat elvis that most people like oh he
was fat elvis for a long time but he
wasn't it was a very good year
i mean i guess at a certain point he was
just like [ __ ] it well he also had he
had some issues too he was uh
look let's move on [ __ ]
this is not the [ __ ] elvis show this
is the [ __ ] batman video are you sure
this is your present to the world for
the for the holiday show
guys like why did we tune in for this
welcome to elvis beyond i'm kevin smith
if you do another hour on elvis yeah
we'll be
about
the q a away from watching hawkeye
together at midnight oh [ __ ]
that's true we can all [ __ ] keep
talking to elvis and make it to hawkeye
so
it's like [ __ ] you stop talking about
elvis to be to keep it back on point
yeah
i'd like to
elvis we said before he was a comic book
fan but he's a big captain marvel fan
and it's reflected in the cape size
so he don't like superman superman wears
a long cape but if you look at elvis
capes which he only wore a few times in
his career not all the time but when he
wore capes it was the captain
marvel-sized kate
there you go internet
[Applause]
relevant to your geeky interests right
there elvis can be still cool for the
comic book kids as well
did um did they tell you the story about
when forrest gump taught him to dance
did that happen in forrest gump
oh that's right he does
my god i haven't seen that in such a
long time the reference went over my
head i was trying to remember i was like
did they mention a [ __ ] thing about
forrest gump maybe i didn't go on the
vip tour
but no that's right in the movie he
[ __ ] teaches all of us i either
never want to talk about elvis again
or
only talk about elvis and make a 24-hour
show
which i feel like at some point we
should do the fact that we haven't in
the
eight years of doing this podcast let's
do it an elvis show already around the
clock like this
oh my god you're speaking my language i
could do a 24-hour show yeah and it
wouldn't be like when mike lindell was
like i'm doing 24 hours and then he did
an hour and walked off i will literally
do 24 [ __ ] hours and [ __ ] all right i
think we need to figure that out for
next year we i mean we do it as like a
you know a fundraiser yeah
can we jerry lewis can't we raise the
funds for ourselves like talking like me
and mark are gonna do 24 hours we're
we're looking to make 20 grand so we can
split 20 grand a piece
we want 10 grand for staying awake for
24 hours there's the towport you better
start ringing in i guarantee you we can
make that money i'd like to raise some
money for the united negro pizza fund
[Laughter]
i will donate some of my money to the
united negro pizza fund
i'm stealing that from a homeless dude
that i saw outside penn station once
like 20 years ago and i gave him [ __ ]
money because that's the best sign i've
ever seen
he was literally out there it was like
cold and rainy out and he had his
[ __ ] bell he's like i'm raising money
if you not [ __ ] pizza fun do not let an
appetite go to waste i was like
[ __ ] here is 20
do not let an appetite go to waste
penn station is for winners
um uh what other news stories do we need
what hoe more news yeah i mean otherwise
i'm gonna start telling you more elvis
[ __ ] yeah
let me tell you the toilet he died on
was on the tour no they don't show you
that they don't oh that because that's
at whatever that's weird yeah they don't
let you upstairs that's where he died
but for the chief reason that like
everybody would be taking pictures of
the [ __ ] bathroom and [ __ ] do you
know though i i had a friend you're
making us do it again the internet is on
fire because we're talking about elvis
in a bad way i'm not talking about elvis
now okay i had a friend who went to uh
to a halloween party at the jackson
family residence ooh
as a child no no like this year oh
they still throw parties every year the
jackson family throws a big fast
halloween party do they really and he
was like you walk through that house and
they have like busts of michael
all over the place like there's thriller
michael let's remember the time michael
there's history michael there's billie
jean michael and he was like
how [ __ ] up is it that their dead
son's face
is like everywhere yeah and like then
they dress it up for halloween
they put like this on it yeah it's on
the bus and then they have like waiters
dressed as michael handing out drinks
wow
that is an on-brand party i was like oh
it all checks out
wow so the news six feet under might be
coming back
um
oh is that right yeah speaking of dead
people
um look i lugged uh six feet under quite
a bit i particularly think it's one of
the best season
series finales of all time and you have
to be a [ __ ] robot not to get
emotional at the series finale even if
you weren't a fan of the whole [ __ ]
show it's so insanely well done
um that being said how is that [ __ ]
relevant to our interests on this show i
know elvis isn't but like
how is this geek worthy this is where
you're calling [ __ ]
yeah you've hit my line mark
i'm just curious what is the geek angle
of this other than like other than you
were a fan and i was like oh kevin will
like this story i do i appreciate it see
done good good good looking out see
sometimes the stories are for me you
[ __ ] bite my head off what what the
[ __ ] we talking about this for because
you like it
okay i don't think i pulled the [ __ ]
word but in my head i was like what the
[ __ ] is he talking about this short why
we could have been talking about elvis
this whole time
like did you did you cross the elvis
barrier because if it's not better than
elvis we're talking about elvis again
the rubicon of elvis
um so yeah that's may or may not be
happening moving on i'm happy that it's
happening is it all i mean like they
they commission the script well based on
the [ __ ]
series finale we know what happened we
know when they all die everybody dies
and we they show us all of their deaths
so it'd be weird to see a little bit
more of their lives going like yeah but
we know what happens i mean technically
we always know what happens to every
story they die that's true but we saw
exactly how each of them [ __ ] died
true
um but you know what they're good
storytellers they'll figure it out i'm
on board excellent glad we sorted that
out um you know what i'm subscribing to
hbo oh i already do so [ __ ] me
uh this year they revealed the names of
the 25 movies added to the national film
registry oh
people joining me in this very exclusive
club indeed clerks made the list last
year not last year two years ago
2019 i believe i mean you wouldn't know
better than me yeah it was while we were
touring jay and zombob reboot because i
was like oh my god like
everything's coming up milhouse this is
amazing
got my feet in the cement now i've got
the film in the national filmmakers who
got added who did i beat that's really
the question what did you beat um the
films that are notable to this audience
yeah
wally made it in 2008
did i beat wally man wally's an amazing
movie fellowship of the ring made it
this year which one is that the first
that is the first i beat [ __ ] peter
jackson you did
to quote him from the [ __ ] trailer
for [ __ ] lord of the rings now is the
time
it's a deep cuts [ __ ] joke isn't it
also it could have been anybody with an
accent in any movie ever
now's the time but everybody who knows
that that's a knife that's not alive do
me a favor tell me in chat if people are
like that's a deep cuts amazing [ __ ]
joke or if people are like as long as
he's not talking about elvis
i don't give a [ __ ] uh you also beat
stop making sense
what yes
jonathan demi's talking heads picture
the first
home video i ever bought at the price of
99 i didn't buy it it was a gift bought
for me wow that's some love yeah um
return of the jedi
i beat richard marquan's return to the
jedi you did on to the list wow man
that's cause all jedi had was a bunch of
[ __ ] muppets
you also beat richard pryor live in
concert oh what a sacrilege pink
flamingos
oh my god they put uh yeah jack
john uh waters thank you i smoked his
name away for a second on the list i
wonder if that's the first time he got
on
uh i don't know something tells me like
hairspray might have hit the list before
but thank god the pink flamingos is on
there very cool indeed wait wait it was
pink flamingos it was pink flamingos was
the first movie he did uh
uh
what was it um
[ __ ]
before pink flamingos yeah one where
divine eats [ __ ] off the ground where's
that pink flamingos
that's pink flamingos the one before
that
whatever i smoked it away good to know
good to know that uh john waters is on
the list too and whatever happened to
baby jane holy [ __ ] really strangers on
a train
those are classy movies those are classy
movies uh well welcome to the club kids
yes how nice um i'm gonna warn you now
we're bringing it down for these last
two news items is there any more down
than my lisa marie presley deep dive
because that was down one of them is oh
uh the first is uh r.i.p
and why do people have to die who died
and
rice and rice passed away and rice
passed away
um it must have happened when i was at
graceland
probably at 80 years old
she was 80. she was 80. she didn't dress
80. she dressed like emo
she's dressed like an immortal witch
oh man
but yeah her son christopher rice
announced her the news of her passing on
anne rice's facebook page what a
successful career yes by any [ __ ]
measurement um and genre
hardcore she made vampires cool again
yeah i mean it's it's and not sparkly
it's hard to it's hard to overstate just
how much of an impact that interview
with a vampire had on that particular
genre yeah because until then it was
just dracula and every version of
vampires were some kind of dracula
pastiche you know it was dracula
nosferatu nosferatu got less love but it
was always like he's an aristocrat in a
suit and he's always coming from
transylvanian always doing [ __ ]
sparkly party [ __ ] and then it was new
orleans and dark and immortal and brad
pitt and tom cruise yeah you know and
who she famously did not want to play
yeah what was that about who did she
want to let's start i don't recall her
choice but i think maybe she wouldn't
like mick jagger or somebody a bit more
rock and roll he would but tom cruise i
thought did a really good job you i i
were a fan of the books right i was a
huge fan of the books i think you know
if you're of a certain age you read
those books in high school um and it was
always the two it was always like
vampire the vamp interview the empire
and the vampire lestat
um
and she she very much was like i don't
think tom cruise is right i don't think
he's got the weight in the heft and then
she saw the movie and she recanted her
criticism she was like i was wrong is
that right yeah and rarely do people do
that admit like no i i bad call he's
phenomenal okay good for her man i
thought it was good that was really good
yeah i mean it remains incredibly
surprising to me that they never made
the vampireless stock because interview
the vampire made a [ __ ] ton of money it
did that they never kept going they
never kept going because well they did
other
vampire movies they did not just not the
director not the center and neil jordan
did that
um yes same guy that did uh
company of wolves and also um you know
which one we call it crying game you're
crying game very excellent film
um but yeah that dude was on a roll for
a couple years with those movies man he
did all right um just this past august
amc announced a new uh interview the
vampire series
with a fellow named sam reed playing
with stott
they got into the ny's business big and
there's a whole sort of cycle and
circuit of new anne rice tv stuff that's
going to be coming out but
it is certainly enough material plenty
she wrote she wrote long and she wrote
hard about vampires and mummies and
werewolves and witches and
erotica she wrote the movie exit to eden
do you remember that that we rosie
o'donnell yeah she wrote that as well
yep dan aykroyd and rosie o'donnell and
fetish gear if nothing says sexy
then
rosie o'donnell and dan aykroyd and
finished
fancy that it was a flop
um what's a uh by any
uh
standard what a successful writing
career very
imaginative uh change the game
um as a writer you hope to do a quarter
of of what she was able to accomplish
and she kept going man there was a
minute where you know [ __ ] those
books were everything and [ __ ] and even
when people turned their attention to
something else she still kept going
still kept going she loved that world
she loved these characters she loved
writing
she lived in new orleans for a decent
chunk of her life and was a fixture in
that town and she'll be buried in a i
think it's the metairie cemetery i think
a plot that the family's had for a while
i don't know if this is accurate but
they told me once that like they
everything
you're all right
okay
um everything there is buried above
ground because you can't
sink it into the earth the earth will
spit it back up because it's marshy or
something yeah the water table is so
high that
it's below ceiling is that right andrew
[ __ ] is that andrew that's andrew
always we got to put a [ __ ] camera on
you man [ __ ]
you gotta be banff man too
yeah they're uh i don't know why i'm
remembering this but i remember going to
venice italy yeah um some 20 some odd
years ago and there was an island off
the coast of venice that is just the
cemetery island
because you can't actually bury anybody
in venice because again it's sinking and
so there's an island that you have to
lease
a mausoleum and you got to keep paying
for it over time and if you can't make
that payment then you will be
um exhumed
not ex yeah just get out get hit the
brakes dig him up and throw his body
into the sea yeah then it becomes you
become cremated
and then they just throw you on the
beach yeah it's in the water much
cheaper this way yeah but the fact that
there's a whole island just for the care
and feeding of dead bodies you give a
[ __ ] what they do with your body after
you're done not especially you don't
have a preference above ground below
ground
i guess i'm a traditionalist so i
suppose you know inter me in the ground
but
i won't be here so
do what you will
i did find you know what i will talk
about elvis for one more second
i'm so glad you brought him up because i
was just about to
i just want to i i remember you telling
the story about lisa murray presley
wanting to put the bracelet on her
father yeah and the kindness of the the
mortuary or the the whatever the guy to
lie to her and tell her that the
bracelet would be on her father's body
for eternity because the body swells
when it decomposes
and so that bracelet is at some point
going to pop off of
dead presley's body and just lie at the
bottom of a coffin
that's how you wanted to talk about
elvis presley
yeah
[ __ ] that dude
sorry did i did i go over the top
somewhere lisa marie presley is like
like [ __ ] wasn't hard enough
is that so that would definitely be the
case uh i i believe so nobody's like got
thinner and [ __ ] what if he's embalmed
they took all the stuff out that was
what i was going to bring up they got
his brain and his heart still in a in a
thing in memphis they didn't put that in
him is it writing new songs
yeah um they've uh they also like you
know took out
his guts to do the autopsy and stuff so
there was a conspiracy about how he
looked heavier
before he died than when they laid him
out in the casket but that was like
that's because we took most of his guts
out to do the autopsy and stuff the
autopsy slims ten pounds yeah that
that's why i was so happy to read that
because i was like [ __ ] right before i
die i'm gonna get as fat as i want
because at the end i'll be like i demand
an autopsy and they'll make me [ __ ]
thin for the burial and [ __ ] nice nice
that somebody else will do the work for
me after all
uh what else we got uh our final story
oh that's it
that is it it's fit to print that's fit
to print even with [ __ ] spider-man
far from home coming out we got no break
and no news there
i am i i i'm [ __ ] muting everything
spider-man related on the internet i
can't [ __ ] wait i literally can't
wait i was excited to see this movie as
i was to see empire strikes back when i
was [ __ ] nine years old man i can't
wait like it [ __ ] sounds
phenomenal you know who even my [ __ ]
wife i was watching the trailer and she
goes i'll go see that and i was like get
the [ __ ] out of here i got so hard right
there i was like oh watch me masturbate
um
well i thought it'd be a losing affair
to be like let's [ __ ] she'd be like
you're out of your mind i was like just
look at it while it happens
i'm gonna take care of business in a
flash
do you know he liked shazam um
well she was into it she just spunk of
hercules she's going to
uh see it with me uh with all of us
we're gonna go see it on thursday and
stuff oh she was down man like a clown i
was like oh because that means i get to
watch the [ __ ] first two one more
time before we go because i gotta like
re-educate her and stuff like this is
what's been happening yeah
can't wait can't wait are you ready to
bring you down one more time oh [ __ ]
i know you were like riding high on
spider-man and now i'm not spider-man
all right what happened
george perez
oh i know this yes the legend is this is
out there yeah it is the legendary
artist whose work on
crisis infinite earths and wonder woman
and the avengers infinity gauntlet what
hasn't he redefined and touched but one
of the most beautiful two of the most
beautiful hands god ever placed on this
earth most gifted hands
revealed uh last tuesday he's been
diagnosed with stage three pancreatic
cancer [ __ ]
um the diagnosis was on november 27th
and at 67 he uh he was given between six
months and a year to live and he's opted
not to undergo treatment
in a statement he says i've been given
the option of chemotherapy and or
radiation therapy but after weighing all
the variables and assessing just how
much of my remaining days would be eaten
up by doctors visits treatments hospital
stays and dealing with the often
stressful and frustrating bureaucracy of
the medical system i've opted to just
let nature take its course i will enjoy
whatever time i have left as fully as
possible with my family friends and fans
he's planning on making one last public
appearance to meet with fans who will
continue signing autographs
but he did retire from comicing in
january 2019 due to health issues
this is not a message i enjoyed writing
he says especially during the holiday
season but oddly enough i'm feeling the
christmas spirit more now than i have in
many years
maybe it's because it will be likely to
be my last or maybe it's because i'm
enveloped in the loving arms of so many
who love me as much as i love them it's
quite uplifting to be told that you've
led a good life
and that you've brought joy to so many
lives and that you'll be leaving the
world a better place because you were
part of it
come on man that's some real [ __ ] right
there that's the [ __ ] face and
the
the unfaceable and facing it with grace
and a sense of
kindness and warmth to share that
um you know whether or not like
you agree with you know
whether he should
continue the fight or whatever
it's [ __ ] heartbreaking that
somebody so [ __ ] talented
is gonna be taken by something so
[ __ ] common
you know if you're going to take an
artist that gifted
you know take it out take them out with
a meteor or some such [ __ ] not something
as common as [ __ ] cancer
they don't have this [ __ ] licked yet
like
yeah but it's
to to quote another
passage from your favorite movies
you know you you can't it's not for us
to decide how much time we have left but
just for us to decide what to do with
the time we have
and he he's decided that i just want to
live the last part of my life as
as i've lived the rest of it which is
maybe i want to draw some i definitely
want to meet some fans i want to do one
more convention
and uh and then go out on his own terms
and i got nothing but respect me too for
that dude
um and i hope he's a sweet man too
he's on comic book man as well yeah we
have a shirt hanging up in the store
yeah i've heard nothing but like
fantastic stories from professionals and
fans alike who just met him at some
point over the years and he just made
their day like in tiny ways
um i saw some guy on twitter say
wouldn't it be great if marvel and dc
could kind of put the beef aside and
reprint jla versus the avengers that's
right because he did that because he did
that art and it's been out of print
forever because neither of them are
willing to give up the potential
royalties to the other guy that would be
really [ __ ] nice and give it all to
george for heaven's sakes yeah or to his
family or to the charity of his choice
or whatever to george he's not gone yet
he's just not opting to go with chemo he
could keep going
you know stranger things have happened
indeed but he is a titan of the industry
and uh we were lucky to have him and
we're lucky to have him for as much time
as he can give us it's
[ __ ] heartbreaking um
but um there's no butt it's just [ __ ]
heartbreaking
way to [ __ ] start with that next time
man
they'll end with some spider-man action
and [ __ ] now we're gonna make a hard
pivot to dick pills so oh yeah
oh yeah
good point things are about to get
really hard uh mark gave you the news
ladies and gentlemen give it up for mark
with the news
uh uh bamf man this isn't me uh uh
checking uh fact checking my friends
here work but is are we missing anything
according to chat
anybody bitching about some [ __ ] we
haven't talked about i don't think so
other than like no more elvis
a lot of people want us to talk about
spider-man which we haven't seen uh a
lot of people were like how did you not
get invited to the premiere because i
feel like everybody got invited to
premiere but us again what a [ __ ]
great question
like what do you think it is what are we
doing wrong i i you know i i've i don't
think i've ever said anything negative
about a marvel movie and [ __ ] and they
know i like a free [ __ ] anything rob
liefeld was there he tweeted 400
pictures of himself from the focus
oh that's being like top shade rob is
like a comic book icon you know you talk
about daddy deadpool so
that makes sense but like you know it
just feels like
we're we're always like hey the latest
marvel movie thing came out
oh god
more you know like what do we got to do
to get [ __ ] invited to the party and
[ __ ] i don't even want to go to the
party i just want to see the free movie
ahead of time bernie who sings i'm a
cheap guy like literally they could
invite me
and they wouldn't have to worry about
like oh he's going to go to the party
you need a bunch of food i'm like no
give it to somebody else like i just
want to see the movie that's it yeah the
karaoke crew like they're all like look
at me with benedict cumberbatch on the
red carpet and stuff so like the scum
and villainy cosplay crew was all there
last night
and i was like where's your [ __ ]
cosplay
just dress up [ __ ] that's our problem
yeah it's it's
it is kind of weird man like i got
invited to all sorts of premieres and
[ __ ] then the premiere of that actually
really go to
they rarely if ever ask i can't remember
the last time i went to a marvel thing
yeah i i i just say it on like here in
case anyone over there like oh we didn't
think he wanted to go
look i'll suck dick to go to a premiere
i don't care whose man come from [ __ ]
[ __ ] holland i don't give a [ __ ] man
i just i want to be in with the cool
kids
you
guys confidence can take you far in life
it can also help in the bedroom
especially when it comes time to step up
to the plate
that's where bluetooth comes in fall is
here and we can all use a stiff breeze
that's right this episode is sponsored
by blue chew
give it up for the good folks who blew
you ladies and gentlemen and an expertly
timed ad read
if i do say so my fine self blue chew
the folks that let you chew your way
to a rigid erection
chew your way to being turgid i believe
that's their
motto yeah i think they love turgid is a
great adword
blue chew is actually a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but in
chewable tablets how about this blue
chew it's not hard but it will get you
there
it's not hard yet oh
[ __ ]
the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days wait you mean
you don't have to go to a [ __ ] dick
doctor and deal with an embarrassment of
like i've come for dick pills and have
the receptionist be like what's wrong
with your dick
[Applause]
i've decided one of those sassy
receptionists
yeah florence henderson was still doing
receptionist work very loud yes uh
now that's a character that i want to
play
like along with the the judge with the
judge
doing both i'll allow it what's wrong
with your dick
it's a court case i'd sit through right
there i'd like to do jury duty for that
like i'm sorry man this is a robbery but
tell me about your dick
uh yeah the best part it's all done
online so no visit doctor's office no
awkward conversations about your dick
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
blue cheese tablets are made in the usa
oh what a [ __ ] that's a big selling
point right there no waiting in line at
the pharmacy yes because i'll tell you
right now whenever i go to the pharmacy
and have to wait in line instantly i
start shopping and i walk out with 200
worth of [ __ ] from cvs when my wife is
like we're getting divorced and i'm like
but this will clean the car it says it
right on the box
all right this is the host endorsement
personalization part where we're
supposed to riff on one of these thought
starters or add our own okay you're
seeing beyond the curtain right now kids
with bluetooth many of you are excited
to see the postman because when your
package has arrived your package has
arrived oh that's a good line right
that's right
they always say first impressions are
important but what about lasting
impressions all right fair enough
impression meaning where you put your
wiener into
sure yeah
it's time to get off the couch and get
back to work and if your tool needs an
upgrade head to bluechew.com
that's pretty like that i got a little
heart on that one that's that was just
dirty flat out [ __ ] filthy
word around and [ __ ] [ __ ] tools hard
t right at the top tool is your [ __ ]
tool ready blue chew will chew your tool
guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence and blue chew can help you
help give you the confidence where it
counts is that right ladies with uh
applauding with a show of hands meaning
applause
is there nothing what is that what did
they say uh there's nothing sexier than
confidence is there truly
nothing sexier than confidence put your
hands together if you agree with that
sentiment
i want to hang out with non-judgmental
you man that was very cool
these are two ladies who like to party i
think i would imagine sexy sexy like a
[ __ ] looks sexy it's like oh my
god that's way sexier than [ __ ] them
being what did they say
confident yeah it's like who has anybody
i've never once in my life been like you
know oh my god we had sex and they're
like what what'd you
how was she i was like she was so
confident
i don't think i've ever heard any woman
describe me as like he was a very
confident lover most of the time they're
just like you know he flailed around he
tried and [ __ ]
he did his best yeah yeah i had to i had
to soothe his confidence he has none or
the confidence of a serial killer
that kind of confidence yeah that's
scary or a con game or it's just like
you think you're gonna come but guess
what [ __ ] ocean's 12 [ __ ]
george clooney's here yeah there's my
crew
here's my grip
you son of a [ __ ] i'm in the nose plays
so call to action please read verbatim
well well done
so if you could benefit from extra
confidence which apparently is very sexy
according to two people in the room this
lady right here i'm just like everybody
that blue chew confidence that we're
talking about
uh when it's time to perform bluetooth
can help and we've got a special deal
for a deal for our listeners try
bluetooth free when you use the promo
code fatman at checkout just play pay
five dollars shipping oh my god even if
you never wanted to have an erection in
your life free is [ __ ] free man
try it out see what a boner feels like
with blue chew
[Applause]
[Music]
why are my pants so tight thank you
i'll give you permission to use that
line see what a boner feels like with
blue
it works in either way right it's like
if i've never had a boner i'm gonna feel
what it feels like or feel what a boner
feels like it's kind of sexy like that
it's better than that [ __ ] tool line
that they use that got me a little hard
at least some blood moved yes so that's
bluechew.com promo code fatman to
receive your first month free visit
bluetooth.com for more details and
important safety information and we
thank bluechu for sponsoring this
podcast we thank the good folks of blue
chew for [ __ ] having the confidence
to sponsor fat man beyond give it up for
the good folks at bluetooth
that was a hard ad read
blue chew uh fat man sounds like an
order from a dominatrix blue chew fat
man
yes mistress okay
damn scope
i think we saw an insight into your sex
life right there with that with a little
miner's flashlight yeah it really went
to work and [ __ ] oh yeah put in work
you're like i am a director
uh ladies and gentlemen there comes a
point in every show
where we uh do the thing that everybody
elvis
you're gonna hear more about elvis who
was pretty amazing um
we uh we like to answer the questions
that the folks uh like to give us and
[ __ ] and uh this is that point of the
show uh we do q a here and banff man is
in charge of giving us those questions
he makes the selections so it makes our
lives a lot easier on us give it up
for jc banff man himself
bam
um i've got a couple uh comments from
chat first oh okay they have thoughts
yeah i'm curious what are their notes uh
sapient haggis said uh any chance at
some point you can give us a shout out
over the pond we stay up
nearly till 7 am watching the show it's
uh you know about that time now in uh
london
wrecking the hell out of our sleep
patterns
so people in london watch us from like 4
00 a.m till 7 a.m um i don't mean i
appreciate that but you know like you
could watch it when you wake up and [ __ ]
but i guess they like the idea of the
live interaction yeah i think i
appreciate that that's [ __ ] cool one
day didn't we do it once in england yeah
we did yeah the london film and comic
con um we'll do it again in england and
[ __ ] and then one day you'll be like
it's on my clock [ __ ] [ __ ]
america
and that's how america got started i
believe in the first place yes it's on
our clock [ __ ] yes
um but thank you thank you for those
oversea thanks oversee overseas thank
you for anyone who's not from [ __ ]
los angeles who watches the show because
we know it comes on at all uh odd time
and goes we're like hawaii hawaii is
we're prime time hawaii is that right
oh my god three hours four hours before
check you out look at this [ __ ]
gorgeous print man
um where'd it come from
um who brought these in
you're the artist get the [ __ ] up here
man jump up here
holy [ __ ]
[Applause]
um are you children
jump up we haven't really [ __ ] met
man so children did the drawing of
this uh guru uh that they're doing for
uh sideshow for sideshow
industries yeah it's the their division
of vinyl toys number one i love your art
look at how [ __ ] cl clever this piece
is it's got so many like deep cuts kevin
smith references most especially the one
that touched my heart was the smith
corona personal award process which i
got from coming to the show that you the
last show you guys did before you went
to go shoot clerks when i talked about
it because you guys talked about your
like pieces that you would have in your
personal museum and i was like oh
writing that down
people actually listen to me in the show
that means someone out there is like
he's right about elvis well i've heard
that i've heard i've heard the pwp story
like another stuff because you posted
pictures of it i actually wanted to ask
you what model of uh moped you had and
the bike that you had that your dad like
mocked up yes cause uh yeah that's a
really good story thank you tom about
this these are [ __ ] dope they're
coming damn soon oh yeah and those i
designed those are coming out next year
and uh 2022 uh mall rats rats
i mean they're literally mall rats look
it's it's jay and silent bob that's mall
rats how did can you see that on camera
um thank you andrew um
so uh chogrin did these did you do the
sculpts as well no i designed those like
i did the 2d ones i think you have one
of the wood prints at your house i do
it's the one that's hanging on my wall
yeah we did them for a gallery in 1988
and um we did the prototypes the beast
brothers did the sculpts um and
you know uh i knew i was kind of sort of
like gambling like maybe he'll like them
and now they're going to be toys so they
they've and i know there's like all
different colored editions and stuff
yeah this is the uh jane shawn bob
strike back edition they're [ __ ]
gorgeous i've seen pictures but i've not
seen them like in person yeah
they're fully well not fully articulated
but they have uh
you know limited articulation yeah their
their wrists move and those are being
released by ubd toys so who's putting it
out uh uvd toys dvd toys uh uvds uvd
tours oh my god they're [ __ ] gorgeous
where can they get them where can people
get this [ __ ] those are coming out in
2022 these are technically my um my
prototypes look at you the prototypes
came in man
[ __ ]
i saw that this was the last show so i
was like oh bring them in i'm so glad
you did oh my god and it's got the
markers cigarettes and everything yeah
that is fantastic jay jay even has like
a little metal ring uh ear i saw that
in his ear my god how awesome does it
feel to like see the drawing 2d drawing
become three-dimensional i'm addicted
like
making toys is like yeah i just want to
keep making that's your thing yeah
[ __ ] i'm so glad that you did this
with us where's the black sharpie
maybe it's under here
no that's orange
coming in
excellent man wow
i'm just gonna say this before we've all
seen the movie but that was like charlie
cox daredevil into spiderman also i'm
like staring right into the light from
home you just caught that [ __ ] without
even looking and just use the falls luke
am i tagging these
yeah yeah you can contact jay on the
chest yeah go for it you can do whatever
you want
can i keep them you're like no
sure
i'm gonna put this one on the back my
god they're [ __ ] gorgeous awesome
thank you i can't wait i gotta get jake
to sign
the j1 as well the j yeah um and also
since i'm here uh the
guru skew
which is a print is also going to be a
toy as well that is going to be a toy
for sure man i think they've i don't
know if they started taking orders on it
yet or no not yet in 2022 we're gonna
you know that's why i was like ah should
i bring them in they're not available
yet but i'm getting a free i'm getting a
preview glad you did i've seen somebody
brought the print in and they signed a
print yeah the prints are available
right now so you get the prints online
kids and where at children's side show
collectibles sideshow collectibles
that's where the prints are and then you
can also i think order the actual guru
sku and these will be available next
year from uvd uvd toys and they'll be
available i think at different uh
retailers as well so [ __ ] dope give
it up for an artist man look at that
[ __ ] bonafide artist chobren
thank you captain
i'll leave your [ __ ] here man you can
grab it on the way out nobody touches
[ __ ] or you can grab it now don't trust
these [ __ ] people yeah yeah smart
plan
a little drunk and high on tater tots
yeah somebody'll be like this shit's
mine toy boy
um all right and there's big i don't
know if this is yours the paper envelope
now oh there's a plastic up here too um
all right banff man what you got all
right uh a couple more comments julio
casada
said uh ask nate to do a poster of kevin
as elvis and mark is little richard for
next show
nate did you hear that personal request
that was [ __ ] nice
and then uh to kind of end elvis and tie
it back into something that and i just
want to point out to everybody i stopped
talking about elvis a long time ago
other people keep bringing him up now
because he's infectious like that yes
kate van d in chat said
please check out suspicious minds by
gwenda bond
uh it's a canon novel from stranger
things it's about 11's
mother and her time in a la in the lab
suspicious minds being the elvis song
so it ties into stranger things
i mean that's a stretch
i mean all it shares with elvis is the
title of a song i thought you were going
to be like suspicious minds is the real
elvis story
like whether they tell you like his
wrist blew up and the [ __ ] bracelet
broke
yep
yeah it did um okay enough about elvis
dude i don't get crucified online people
be like this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
ruined he-man and he won't stop talking
about elvis
uh okay uh first question uh for q a
thomas d
thomas d get your ass up here man
as thomas d makes his way up i'll tell
you what thomas d is going to win if he
uh well he's going to win if he gets uh
asked us a question that produces an
answer at all
uh let's be honest thomas d is getting
this [ __ ] regardless number one he's
going to get this signed print from uh
the good old dark nate himself nate
gonzalez does our show art every year
every episode uh every week and uh
here's me and mark as daredevil and
kingpin so you get one of those that's
signed by me and mark and nate the
artist himself and not one of those
that's not that i was like we're giving
out rub-offs
uh then of course you're gonna get some
tickets thanks to our good friend brett
deacon some 40x
tickets now this ticket is [ __ ]
insanely valuable how much is it to go
see a 40x movies like 20 bucks 600 600
[ __ ] dollars
and you're gonna get to go for free
there's two of them right here so that's
a 1200 value ladies and gentlemen
so whoever asks questions like tommy d
here is going to walk away with a poster
and going to walk away with uh tickets
we don't have any
[ __ ] manscape [ __ ] or anything this
week sorry your balls are on no dick
products for you and stuff
although blue chew i hear you can get
for free
um all right
what do you got for us all right so
where are you from uh los angeles los
angeles right on so this wasn't so much
a hassle
jc is about to shove the mic into your
face there all right uh so when y'all
were breaking the first season of master
of the universe revelation did you all
have like a rough idea where each
character was gonna network do you have
input from like the powers that be to
tell you no this character's gonna end
up here
a mixture of both like uh you know
they're i had parameters galore on the
gig because it's not my characters and
stuff so there was a plan going in of
like
let's take the two guys out
so we can focus on all the characters
and then bring the two guys [ __ ] back
in
um
the
character arcs and stuff like that
like improved from the outline because i
went back and read my outline and some
[ __ ] is laid out very clearly in the
outline and then some [ __ ] came from
everybody coming into the writer's room
and going like what if we did this what
if we did this
so
um i'm trying to think like ultimately
it was a group effort and we discovered
it some things we knew you know like
adam would
get killed but of course he'd come back
um
and of course we knew tila was going to
become the sorceress that was like a
mattel mandate from the beginning
they're like we want her to become the
sorcerer so that was a big part of our
story um they wanted um
uh adam to
uh
show
a lot
more adam than we had shown in the past
um they wanted to build up the character
of adam himself that you know change his
appearance he looks younger like he did
in the
in the 2000 uh edition of the show
whatever year that
that version came out but definitely
there were some parameters where they
were like this is what we're going for
this is what we're going for uh things
like beast man's arc
came together insanely collectively like
in fact the
the
spoilers or whatever the [ __ ] like him
turning into
um
uh you know battle dog
like it started as a reference in the
script that tim sheridan had written
where you know eva lim was like i should
turn you into my little battle dog
saddle and all and the powerhouse
animation kids
sent us a design of battle dog and we
were like oh that's not literal and
they're like we think it should be this
is [ __ ] amazing so like can't you
have her
like the way adam turns you know cringer
into into battle cat turn beast man into
battle dog like because he's so in love
with her and he's just like you asked me
if i was manor beast which was another
line in the script
they were like can't we call that
linebacker like in in moments like that
you had directors whose job it is to
draw the pictures and make sure the
whole story is there working as writers
as well they were just as [ __ ]
responsible for the storyline and that's
not me trying to like spread it around
be like blame those [ __ ] but i'm
saying they brought something to the
table as well where even as like the
head writer i was like well i haven't
even thought about doing that that's
[ __ ] clever i like your show way
better than [ __ ] mine
so yeah there were definitely things
that we knew we were going to do but
then discoveries that we got to make
along the way but always with parameters
it was always bowling with bumpers in
the gutters ball could never go in the
gutter because
there's mattel and there's netflix
telling you exactly what they want
um that was how i took it you yeah i
mean it's always
there's always that mixture especially
with working with somebody else's
characters of yeah you're not going to
kill that dude you're not going to do
that but the remember discovering the
orco
arc in the room where it was like
wouldn't it be cool if we could do like
orco the white
and also the big thing was like wouldn't
it be cool if we could make orco
cool enough that people would get him as
a tattoo
because the general consensus was there
were people that of course liked orco
but a lot of people were like that was
the most irritating aspect of the
[ __ ] show so we were like what if we
made him like you know at first he plays
the character they all know but then
he takes this [ __ ] journey where he's
weakened and [ __ ] but then
finds the inner courage and has this
weird friendship with lynn that like
brings out the best in him and then you
know sacrifices himself but knowing that
of course we can orco the white him like
there was a lot of lord of the rings
polls and references for a project that
was oversaw by a guy who was not a big
lord of the rings [ __ ] fan or not not
a fan just didn't i wasn't way familiar
with the books or the movies like so
much so these kids all the time the
other writers would be like oh we'll do
it like this just in this and i was like
what is that they're like it's a hobbit
thing i was like oh [ __ ] whatever
they're gonna sing no can't we just do a
star wars thing
um but so yeah i'm back to you sorry no
that's it it's just it's it's an always
organic thing and sometimes those
bumpers are not bad
you know the fact that that you know the
enemy of limited the absence of
limitations is the enemy of art like
there's always the feeling that say it
again the absence of limitations is the
enemy of art say it again
well define that for me it means that if
you could do whatever you wanted to do
yes the art doesn't flourish as much as
you have borders
what that's what's wrong with my career
i just keep doing whatever the [ __ ] i
want that's how i get to yoga it's it's
the like
we have enough money to shoot this thing
in this place it's got to be black and
white it's got to be this oh so i'm then
i'm not that guy right clerks those
figured [ __ ] out there's always
limitations unless you're like jj and
you can have as much money as you want
as much time as you want in the cash you
want but i'm sure even him it's like you
got to hit this deadline you got to hit
this date you got to hit this stuff yeah
i mean there look there's a movie
hegemony and as much as like you know
pecking order and people are [ __ ]
city-states and other people are
boroughs and [ __ ] but at the end of the
day we all bow to the same rules which
is you've got this much [ __ ] time and
this much money go
and it don't matter who you are don't
matter if you're [ __ ] steven
spielberg there's always a sort of
damocles of a ticking clock hanging over
your head and the sword of damocles of
like don't you go over this [ __ ]
budget figure this is what it costs if
you go over that you [ __ ] failed yeah
and that that maxim i think applies to
every kind of art and ultimately the
limitations
are our own talent to a certain degree
our own gifts it's how do you how do you
take account and how do you you
dodge around the fact that like hey i'm
a horrible artist well i'm going to be a
writer okay you can do this i'm horrible
at romance i'm going to do this you know
if you're an artist i'm horrible at
hands or feet so i'm going to be rob
lightfelt or if you're lo
i got the second rob lifefelt [ __ ]
dick um
or you could be like look i suck at
everything ooh i can be kevin smith and
that's your thing
but but limitations force you to be
creative because otherwise you would
just do the first thing that comes to
your mind it doesn't make you
interrogate it doesn't make you iterate
do the easy thing you do the easy thing
because it's there but the limitations
are what forces you to come up with a
solution that you might not have already
come up with and so having somebody say
can't kill that dude can't kill that
dude can't kill that lady force you to
say well how do we get drama out of it
if that is not the thing we can do
all too often death is an easy way of
motivating story but if you can't do
that then how do you make it still work
how do you make it dramatic how do you
make it emotional how do you make it
suspenseful if you know that they're not
going to die and i think that that's the
challenge and that's when it gets to win
because we've done the work you know you
you've earned the audience's trust and
their desire to go with you because they
found something new just as we did in
the room that we didn't know we were
going to find on the way in and
necessity being the mother of invention
sometimes just by story need
you stumble into incredibly cool [ __ ]
where you're like nobody brought this to
the table nobody came into the room
going how about this and whipping their
big story dick out or something like
that but suddenly because you've set up
all these rules over here it backs you
into this [ __ ] corner where you're
like oh [ __ ] well now we got to make
sure this works out and because of that
you discover something completely new
and the story gets better it's been it's
an interesting process having
like having having bumpers so to speak
yeah i mean it's always the the the job
of writing comics for like marvel or dc
is the here's the character in the toy
box you can pick it up you can play with
it for a little bit but the character
goes back in the toy box pretty much as
you found it
and so how can you make a thing that
cannot change
fun you know how do you how do you live
in the second act where there's no
beginning and there's no end there's
just middle but still make it
interesting and making it you know
dramatic and all that stuff and that's
that it can be it can be you know
head-bangingly frustrating but it can
also be incredibly liberating
and it's just finding that way through
that is a great question that got great
two answers give it up for him man he
just won himself some cool [ __ ]
[Applause]
i
[Applause]
one of our amazing [ __ ] writers uh
gave us the gave him that box the the uh
sweet ass [ __ ]
masters the universe revelation box one
of which i did not get myself
uh they wanted me to sign this because
it says 37 on it that's adorable i'm
gonna scratch off
you lost though right
well i don't know if if i sign it it may
negate it they may be like you [ __ ]
graffitied that [ __ ]
i know but that's three bucks man
how's james where's she
fair enough
just tell her i didn't feel good tonight
but i still [ __ ] came
i didn't feel good tonight because i
made my first batch of hummus tonight uh
earlier today
my own hummus i'm finally free of the
[ __ ] shackles of the [ __ ]
hummus industrial complex why because i
want to be the master of my own destiny
not [ __ ] leaving it all up to sabra
and [ __ ] like that man i want to be able
to feed my goddamn self so i leron who's
our dp on clerks three
um taught me how to make humas as he
calls it and my god
it turned out [ __ ] wonderful i do say
so myself so much so that i ate way too
much of it so i'm farty and [ __ ] full
of hummus but i'll tell you right now
when the show's over i'm gonna eat the
other half of that [ __ ] bucket man
because it's food i made i made that
food mark me i was the one who put my
hands together made a [ __ ] meal now
somebody on twitter was like you pressed
a button on a blender [ __ ]
yes they stole my [ __ ] shine but
they can't taste the steal the taste of
the hummus it tastes so good when i was
a kid i had a neighbor very lovely woman
who like made a bunch of her own foods
and not like a person who cooks
but like i'm making peanut butter
and i'm like why
i can get behind that that sounds fun no
it's awful they do it at whole foods you
could sit there and make your own peanut
butter [ __ ] that jiff that [ __ ] because
i for real don't want some improvised
oil-based peanut sauce
can we please get jiff as a sponsor of
the show
and have mark's catchphrase be like [ __ ]
that jiff that [ __ ] said [ __ ]
jeff for serious [ __ ] she used to
make ketchup and it was the worst
thing i'm like it's right they did it
for you already they perfected it
because she was like i don't believe in
all the sugar and salt they put us but
that's why it tastes good that reminds
me of uh
ketchup water vacation when uh they go
to cousin eddie's house and uh [ __ ]
um clark goes to use the ketchup and he
pulls out the spoon and it's got like
seeds and he goes
real tomato ketchup eddie and he goes
nothing but the best he made his own
[ __ ] ketchup no
no garbage water
um well my hummus turned out great is
all i'm [ __ ] saying good for you but
i stayed downwind i didn't yes
i'm trying to squeeze clench all night
long but i felt like a kind of ill but i
was like the show must go on so tell
james
next time weak sauce yeah [ __ ]
she can't if if i can make it here
so full of hummus i'm ready to vomit
she was like if he talks about elvis it
will
tear my heart apart
um all right where are we going next uh
kristen
kristen get up here and ask us some [ __ ]
give it up
i should point out we signed a bunch of
prints uh and we were given two that are
behind us
uh chris mcdonald did these lovely
[ __ ] prints
of of us doing fat man beyond and it's
me and it's you and it's [ __ ] banff
man
popping in like like a night crawler
bamfing in and [ __ ] i signed it but i
didn't even see it what am i doing you
signed a bunch of [ __ ] didn't even look
at it and [ __ ] good thing it wasn't like
an insurance company oh so which i just
signed and uh me being an alcoholic is a
sign it's a drawing of you being drunk
and you're wearing your b humble bullet
motherfucker's nose yeah and you're
signing a bunch of [ __ ] and just looking
at it funny
and banff man is appearing out of
nowhere like i am not i drink like i had
a drink i had two maybe that's what you
get out of this beautiful artwork you're
like i am not a drunk
[Music]
i i like that you're drinking skywalker
wine with a straw in it class i'm classy
yes
um banff man you're in the piece i know
that always makes you feel happy you're
like i like to be included i think it's
somewhere andrew was rolling a tear gone
what the [ __ ] where's my participation
trophy i think it's my first fan art
like that somebody put me in and then
printed one and was like this is for you
like they gave me a copy [ __ ] and i
haven't popped your cherry
yeah are you gonna get it framed
i probably will i sent it to jen and
she's like that's really cool i was like
it'll go in the house
why can't i'm not that cool
put it up in your bar
yeah um that's dope all right let's over
to you what's your name again i'm
kristen everyone give it up for
christmas man she's been waiting to ask
this question
all night long kristen what can we do
you for all right so hi kevin and mark i
have a double question double question
so kevin um what is the best acting
advice you gave harley and mark as a new
director what is the best acting advice
you have so yeah double question best
acting advice i gave my kids less advice
and more stern warning i said don't
[ __ ] blow anybody
she took me very seriously
um no big advice i gave her was just
like oh my god do it
like act make pretend for a living what
could be better than that and you know
my wife wanted her to go to college and
harley was indicating she didn't want to
go to college
and jennifer was like you got to back me
up and she got to go to college and [ __ ]
because like acting how often does that
work out for people and i'm like you're
talking to somebody it worked out for
like i can't literally
advise my kid in a way that i would not
have advised young kevin smith at her
same age like i tried to go to college
and stopped because i realized it wasn't
for me why make her do that like if
she's not gonna be into it like if she
knows what she wants to do in life let's
let her lean into it and stuff so you
know
jen kind of pushed college for a good
like two years
and i was the one
not saying like [ __ ] your mother ignore
her but i was just like i get what
you're doing man like i'm all for it
like and so much so i was really
irresponsible because she's like i don't
even need high school anymore i was like
you're right quit at age 16 and my wife
was like you're [ __ ] nuts and i was
like no clerk's worked out she's like
for you she's not gonna make clerks and
[ __ ] but i was like yeah but if she's
gonna like wants to follow her [ __ ]
passion
that's how i got here that's literally
how i met you that's how the girl came
into this world so i got a supporter on
that um so that was it i was just like
look do it if you want to do it commit
to it and [ __ ] do it don't listen to
anybody else you know best this is your
one and only [ __ ] life and up until
now we've been in charge of it to make
sure that you don't [ __ ] die that's
our job to keep you alive now you're a
grown ass adult you can start making
decisions for your own if this is what
you want to pursue with your life and
your life is young right now which means
that like [ __ ] 10 years from now if
you change your mind you'll still be
[ __ ] young enough to do that but if
this is what you're feeling [ __ ] go
for it 100 man because stranger things
have happened it works out for people
plus i know a director who'll cast you
in every [ __ ] thing he makes so
you'll have that and she was like great
[ __ ] kevin smith movies
but um yeah i was big into like please
just do it don't not do it don't listen
to anybody a lot of people she went to a
school that was all college prep
like and there are only two people that
ever graduated from her high school that
didn't go on to college and when my kid
didn't want to apply to colleges they
brought jen in and sat her down and they
were like you have to sign off on the
fact that your kid doesn't want to apply
anywhere because this school has a long
story tradition of placing people in
college this is a college prep program
and stuff
and my wife was like you know i had to
sit there i was on tour she was like i
had to sit there and be lectured and i
want her to go to [ __ ] college and
[ __ ] you should have been there it's
like i wish i would have been there i
would have been like yeah that is true
that's one way to look at it and the
other way is just like her dad made
clerks how the [ __ ] could she possibly
go to college like
so
i told her to lean into it and it's
panned out she's happy and she could she
works and stuff like that so
it seemed like good advice you
um
i think
from it's it's a lesson i learned i
think like my first or second writer's
room
and i think it applies both to writers
building characters and actors building
characters which is
everybody lies at least half the time
and so when you're writing a character
and how they into the world and how they
greet other people even how they feel
about themselves
they are almost never 100 honest about
it you know we all tell ourselves little
lies all the time and we tell everybody
else that lies all the time and so when
you are building a character when you're
starting to do that kind of interior
work
even if it's physicality even if it's
just a mindset just remember this
person's probably lying about it
and so as time goes on if the story is
worth its salt we'll begin to reveal
those lies over time
um i remember
listening to an interview with damon
lindelof about lost and he said that you
know when they were writing the pilot he
and jj decided that every character
would have a secret and that at some
point we would find the truth about that
secret that sawyer's problem was his
mother you know was killed by a con man
and so he decided to be the con man that
like all of those things began to add up
to who those characters were and it's
the thing they don't tell anybody the
thing they don't even really admit to
themselves at some point but it informs
and animates and fuels everything that
they do
and so just that little bit of of kind
of human
[Music]
scholarship i guess of
inauthenticity from a character
perspective is as important as
authenticity
from the
i'm not going to be honest with anybody
you know how you doing pretty good
always a lie
you know i lean into it how are you i'm
outstanding like really no nobody's
outstanding have you been in the world
uh my standard response people like how
are you i'm like so good
and you know every third person is like
oh so good why they want to know why
yeah so really no not outstanding i'm
fine i mean it though when i say so good
i know well you're usually high
that helps to give an easy honest answer
um but yeah they smell me they're like
oh i understand i get it oh yeah just in
that you know i i don't really have the
tools yet to give like for real acting
advice
like faster more intense
george lucas school of acting um yeah
don't point at me like that's my
direction because we made a joke about
it we did it earlier but when you were
like
thank god you said george lucas because
i was going to quickly be like he's
talking about george lucas he's not
pointing at me and meaning i do that
call back um but i think that that
lots of the creation of character is
similar from a writing perspective as it
is from an acting perspective who is
this character what do they want what
are they willing to do to get it and how
honest are they about themselves along
that path and so just
tuck it away like maybe it'll come in
handy maybe it won't but just like
what's this person lying about
yeah i'm gonna start making little
secrets yeah [ __ ] it with me oh [ __ ]
don't is that what you got out of what
he said make a little don't listen to
him don't lie to people not everyone you
meet lies to in fact everything i told
you about elvis tonight totally true
or is it
yeah we'll find out precisely when we
read that book suspicious minds that
mark was talking about i wasn't talking
about you lie i know you're a good point
like mark said we all lie uh excellent
question that deserves a poster and
tickets give it up for a lady thank you
guys well done thank you
[Applause]
enjoy
all right jc that's two
two of three we have one poster and two
tickets left
okay and i apologize for my
pronunciation imran
all right goodbye he did it he did it
right give it up for him ron
[Applause]
how are you captain pretty good how are
you so [ __ ] congrats to both clerics
three splinter shorts thank you welcome
aboard thank you um okay my question is
what is a film or tv show that you
return to in order to process an emotion
so like for example
swingers if you're going through a
breakup pursuit of happiness to be
inspired want a vision for grief this
year
positive negative emotion whatever i
have gone back to wanda vision just to
get that like
rush of of grief like i sometimes i love
misery porn in my entertainment and my
music if something's gonna make me feel
something something make me cry
something make me go oh my god like i
will i'll seek it out and watch it
um again and again one of my favorite
movie moments of all time and and the
way i understand it this for men of a
certain age this carries across to a lot
of people is um
kevin costner in field of dreams
speak oh my god i'm going to cry doing
it speaking
to his father
and like having a very like kind of
normal conversation about like is this
heaven he's like i don't know blah blah
and his dad is
like kevin costner finally breaks down
you hear his voice crack and he goes dad
you want to have a catch
and he's like i would love that and they
[ __ ] start playing catch
still [ __ ] destroy i don't give a
[ __ ] about baseball
never have
but baseball movies make me [ __ ] cry
moneyball makes me [ __ ] cry the
ending of moneyball when when he when
they go over that clip of like what
baseball means about the guy who like
you know it's that play and he's like
everybody's laughing and [ __ ] but that
[ __ ] play was like this huge moment
just [ __ ] destroys me the bad news
bears
um is a movie that emotionally [ __ ]
destroys me i don't have much connection
to baseball i find the game boring but
baseball movies really [ __ ] do it for
me for some reason so yeah there's a lot
of art that i go to to just make me go
like
you know get the heart [ __ ] pumping
and it also gets me going and
shows up
in my work where i'm like oh i want to
[ __ ] do some of that
um the succession season finale this
year they had a great year the season
finale was a stunning [ __ ] piece of
entertainment and that had me like
emotionally engaged
uh as well like you felt
you have to be
i know like a lot of people talked about
the jeremy strong [ __ ] new yorker
profile and [ __ ] but you would have to
be a robot not to feel for his
performance of kendall in that episode
as he broke down when he was just like
i'm in a million pieces like
you know that's that's a performance you
could [ __ ] feel coming right out of
the tv and you shouldn't even feel bad
for this [ __ ] billionaire rich kid
but his performance is so [ __ ]
compelling it just [ __ ] takes you
there so yeah those are just a few that
that [ __ ] do it for me feel the
dreams is an absolute [ __ ] go-to juan
division i returned to that last episode
over and over again particularly for
when you know um we will see each other
again oh that [ __ ] destroys me
um so yeah i'm i'm a fan of that kind of
[ __ ] a big time i don't know about you
um
every day when i was driving to the set
to shoot the short
at some point on the drive-in i would
play what's-up danger no
and because that scene in that movie
is
not about a guy being not afraid
it's about a guy being afraid and doing
it anyway
you know it's why when he's pulling away
the glass breaks of his hand like he's
not yet ready to let go but knows that
he has to and so that feeling of being
on the edge of something that you're not
quite ready for but you go anyway
like every day yeah what's up danger
let's [ __ ] go let's go make a movie
because i wasn't sure
you know but that's that's
that's the job of living right like
doing [ __ ] that you're afraid of but
doing it anyway that's what courage is
you know it's not it's not action in in
spite of fear it's action in the face of
fear
and so not that i was brave for making a
[ __ ] movie
but you make your choice and then you
try to be the person you're supposed to
be in that moment and so that feeling of
you know all you needed is to believe
for a second that you could be that
person and let go of that wall
and then soar
or fall
either one but you let go
and so that's that's what kind of
powered me through the front end of that
and then by the end i was just a mess
anyway so it'll it all panned down i
would say though the tweet was brave the
one that you reposted
putting it out there like that you know
it's it's
i i and i do not in any way mean to
denigrate the the heroism of people who
are like firemen or police officers or
whatever but like when a fireman goes or
a firefighter goes into a building and
saves somebody's life that's not the
moment they're a hero the moment they're
here is when they sign on the line to
become a firefighter in the first place
because then you know that's the job
like you're doing the job you signed up
to do but you signed up to do it like
that's the moment when you're a [ __ ]
hero and so you know
making the movie i suppose was just a a
uh
a connective tissue to that original
thing of like i'm i wanna do this i'm
gonna put into the world so the world
holds me accountable
you know it's just the manifestation of
the thing that you were dead set on
doing like it was happening regardless
and when you would make the thing
that was just a
formality yeah it's the end of that road
that you started down to begin with and
you know at any point you could back
away and nobody would hold it against
you like it's hard and it's a long shot
but
so much of life is hard in a long shot
that you're just gonna have to bet on
yourself at some point and and don't let
the fear keep you from doing the thing
that you want to do because everybody's
afraid and everybody's you know
uncertain and unfounded and they feel
like they're on shaky ground
but
people get it done anyway and so
act as if
you're the person who can do that
like elvis
like elvis
uh what a great question what a great
answer give it up for him
get yourself your tickets in your poster
well done and wrong
excellent job
um
uh end game tony stark dying also is a
go-to
emotional moment for me
um ev yes spoilers sorry
in case people are holding out for
spider-man far from home or no way home
um the uh
you know the the [ __ ] snap alone you
know when he the gloves on his hand
you're like
it's a real like audience cheer kind of
moment
um his [ __ ] like you know and i
am iron man and he [ __ ] viciously
snaps him which i [ __ ] love to death
it's the biggest [ __ ] you he's like like
he wants to hurt this [ __ ]
um but watching him [ __ ] like die and
not respond to like spiderman oh my god
that destroys me each time when pepper
starts talking to him she's like
[Laughter]
i'm such a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
can't help it it's so [ __ ] emotional
and then when you watch that like helmet
cam and he's like i love you 3000 and he
[ __ ] you know pieces out that that
will do it for me every time the end of
uh cinema paradiso when the director
watches the montage of all the kisses
that were cut out of all the movies like
oh my god i just i just weep like a
child each time and those are go-to's
for me if i want to write something
emotional you know generally i could get
in touch with my emotions pretty easily
obviously but if i really want to guild
the lily i will watch something that
just [ __ ] makes me [ __ ] cry and
then be like now i'm gonna take this
[ __ ] out on others you know [ __ ]
spread my pain and stuff i love that
what makes you cry
like what movies and tv shows where you
go back to them you're like oh i [ __ ]
love that there's an episode of the west
wing that i watch every thanksgiving
it's called shibboleth it's the seventh
or eighth episode of the second season
and it's the big part of the episode is
like there's a bunch of chinese refugees
who have come in and like a container
ship and you know much of the episode is
about like how they deal with that
problem and how you how you can divide
whether or not a person is actually you
know
under religious persecution or whether
they just want to escape a totalitarian
regime whatever there's a tiny sea story
it's like the this it's a three-beat
story in this whole episode about the
president's assistant charlie played by
dooley hill who's trying to buy a knife
for his boss to carve a turkey
and it's like it's a comedy bit like
every time he'll go outside i got the
new knife and martin sheen is the
president and be like all right let's
take a look who's taping along the blade
allows for complete sharpening whatever
i don't think i want a japanese knife
you want a german one want a german one
then charlie will away and come back
he's like uh i got this one for you it's
like i don't know about it not sure and
the third beat charlie goes brings
another knife and the president's like
i'm not sure i don't like it and charlie
goes with all due respect sir
these mean a lot to you clearly don't
you already have a knife
and it's like i do then why do you need
a new one well i'm giving this one away
to whom it's like funny you should ask
and then he brings out the box with a
knife i'm going to get choked up talking
about it he brings his box with a knife
a little bow around it he's like charlie
i'm proud of you he's like i just want
to let you know and he's like oh wow i
don't recognize the make you know
because he's been researching knives all
[ __ ] episode and he's like who all i
see is on the box it says pr he's like
well these knives are made for my family
by a boston silversmith named paul
revere
he gave charlie the knife
every thanksgiving watch that and i cry
in my turkey every [ __ ] year because
it's just got me a little misty even
though i'm like what is he [ __ ]
talking about but i think your emotion
caught up to me i was like oh the story
of these two guys like charlie you know
was just a [ __ ] wanted a messenger
job and he shows up at the white house
and suddenly the person listening to the
president and the president has no sons
charlie's parents are gone it's just him
and his sister and there's like slow
building of this relationship between
these two
and this is the first time you see what
charlie means to the president as
opposed to what the president means to
charlie
and just that the depth of that gift
and the fact that it's a [ __ ] comedy
beat
that you don't think is going to hurt
you
until it's a [ __ ] sucker punch to the
nuts when he's like
i'll give you this knife charlie paul
revere made it for my family
every year i watch it my wife is like
could you watch like another thing no
um bamf oh yes i'll give you my two
which make me cry
but it's not
the emotional cry of like field of
dreams it's like a release cry okay
which was i like those cathartic
crying's really powerful for years
we got teased with cap
getting thor's hammer yeah and i just
watched end game
three days ago and i fast forwarded to
that part because i had two kids helping
me pack boxes at the house and i was
like you want to see my tv and they're
like yeah let's see the big tv i just
got a big tv
and uh
and i put it on i'm with these two 22
year old kids
i'm like oh [ __ ]
because i am crying yeah and they're
like that's a big tv and i'm like
like there's just something about like
when he grabs it and then hemsworth's
like i knew it
that gets me every time and then the
other one that got me
was i re-watched just the scene where
luke skywalker show spoilers in mando
season 2. that will reduce a grown up
anybody any grown-up of a certain age
who grew up with [ __ ] luke skywalker
as their childhood hero to absolute
tears it was the
you know [ __ ] promise
of
that we thought we were getting with the
the you know the last trilogy and
they delivered on mandalorian instead to
be like look at your childhood hero look
at what he can still do look at he
became
a jedi master like that's what i loved
about it i was like i was so invested in
this motherfucker's training and he left
early and [ __ ] yoda warned him and
[ __ ] and then eventually yoda was like i
was kidding you're a real jedi but like
[Laughter]
i just [ __ ] with you yeah it was all
good that was the last movie i'm dying
now [ __ ] it but
but then eventually like we we got to
see him
be the jedi master not like the guy
still going through [ __ ] and [ __ ]
return of the jedi and saving his dad at
the last minute but just a [ __ ] jedi
knight
who like takes out a room full of people
the way his dad did in the hallway
sequence on rogue one is incredibly
powerful i walked into the house and jen
was like what's what's wrong like are
you okay and immediately i started like
well luke shows up
[ __ ] that came out two years ago what's
the matter with
well i just watched it again i still get
really [ __ ] dusty at the iron giant
oh super
mad
like i remember i was in a screening
room
uh i was at entertainment weekly it was
like 1999. nobody knew anything about
this movie like it was this very under
the radar thing and i went because i'm a
nerd and it's [ __ ] brad bird who i
liked and it's you know [ __ ] an
animated movie so i'm gonna go i
remember sitting in that in that
screening with like three other people
and like kind of just bopping along with
us oh this is cool this is fun and then
when when iron giant thinks that hogarth
is dead
and he goes [ __ ] metal and you see
like a robot crying like he's like
huddled over and he's like
and then he like activates and i started
to [ __ ] weep like not even the
superman the superman was the [ __ ]
icing on the cake but the
just that that push into fury into
despondence
there is no reason for me to have a
connection to humanity because you took
the one thing that i loved away
and he just like going [ __ ] ham on an
army just exploding tanks and like
sending nukes into the water and
all of it until hogarth isn't dead and
like he's reminded that there's some
good left in the world that's worth
saving and then you get the superman
moment i was a mess for those like eight
minutes
of just like i don't know what's
happening this wouldn't oh he's a gun
this is cool and sad and and and
courageous and bleak all at once
i and then just walked out of that
screening with the other three people
going did you see that [ __ ] movie and
like i know
is anybody else gonna see this movie
probably not
it's opening against the matrix
is that what happened i i think it it
got swallowed by the rest of it because
that was also a warner brother it was
also a warner brothers movie and they
had like no confidence in it so they
just dropped it and let it go and it has
this life on video and then dvd and then
on cable and then it's become what it
was always meant to be which is a
classic he's such a gifted storyteller
brad bird i'll like one of my favorite
sequences in a movie of all time and i
will watch it over and over again
um it's emotional but not where you like
cry and [ __ ] but you are so [ __ ]
gripped
is the missile lock sequence in the
incredibles still a [ __ ] i mean this
is a [ __ ] cartoon
and a cartoon
mom who [ __ ] stretches and and turns
into like a raft and [ __ ] like that and
somehow
it is one of the most thrilling
sequences ever in a movie where she's
like you know they're they're you know
they're they're children on board aboard
a border board and you're like these
[ __ ] are going to send missiles at
the ship and she's like like get in the
bag and like buckle your seatbelt like
it is so [ __ ] intense right i need to
make a force field around us right now
it's like i can't i can't i love that
and she's like violet you have to do it
she's oh holly hunter is so [ __ ] good
in that scene man it's such an
incredible sequence and they blow the
[ __ ] plane up yeah and let them
[ __ ] like drop to the ground the kids
are like screaming that movie gets so
[ __ ] real so quick in that sequence
this is indian golf nine or nine and we
are bunny spiked i don't know what any
of those words mean yeah but i know
that's bad abort abort abort and then
craig t nelson is [ __ ] mr incredible
is like held up on the thing like
listening to his family get incinerated
in mid-air
i'm now i want to go watch both the iron
guys
and the incredibles like back to back
until two in the morning and [ __ ] and
just be like crying my eyes out like god
life is so beautiful um that's what we
do here on this show ladies and
gentlemen we talk about [ __ ] that
happened years ago
and make it feel like it just happened
yesterday and [ __ ] like from the iron
giant giant to elvis himself
this was a classic oldies sentimental
show and the last one of the year the
last live show the last live show of the
year we might do a show next week a zoom
show because we have to talk about
spider-man that's right so we'll
definitely let's say we'll definitely do
a home show but this is the last time we
get to do it um in the room uh you know
for 20 21 how many times do you think we
did it in the room over 2021 when did we
start doing it with people back in the
room uh we did a couple in june
then by the three
oh yeah and then
i don't know maybe ten yeah nine or ten
yeah
next year we'll do better
um look i'm shocked we did it at all i'm
always so delighted when people like
i'll risk a [ __ ] omicron to go out
and [ __ ] laugh
this motherfucker's dad jokes and
chilling um means the world that you all
come out and uh join us here everybody
here in the room means the world the
folks watch
at home of course and stuff but like you
know folks that are like
man i'll go that seems like fun you know
sometimes you got a bunch of regulars
people who are here all the time which
is wonderful and then sometimes you get
people who are like i've just watched it
forever and it seemed like a good time
and then they tell you that they had a
good [ __ ] time and stuff and then
people travel from all over the country
and in times all over the world to come
and sit in this bar with us
as we tell
dick jokes yeah
yeah it's kind of beautiful man isn't it
so thank you honestly
and your
faith and fellowship has allowed
one of us to go [ __ ] direct his first
feature give it up for director mark
bernard
[Applause]
[Music]
and and there are some of the people in
this room who helped make that happen so
again thank you to everybody who was a
kickstarter supporter who was a
background player and who decided to
come and watch us do a dumb show
um he's quick with a sharpie and many
factoids ladies and gentlemen one day
we're gonna get camera back there on him
and stuff so you could see him as he
cucks out on the rest of the show give
it up for andrew he's in the back man he
deserves your love
[Applause]
we don't uh have a [ __ ] place to do
this show uh without ban man himself
giving up the proprietor of the scum and
villainy candina
right here in hollywood on hollywood
boulevard jc himself
and
we
were the pre-show for hawkeye by the
time everybody gets home hawkeye's gonna
be on so you're welcome i don't know if
i i might i might watch the incredibles
and iron giant
before i go in a hawkeye because i'm
really feeling it right now
um if you're in uh uh out here on
saturday ladies and gentlemen we are
doing the last hollywood babylon of the
year over at flappers the comedy club in
burbank our very first debut over there
uh me and ralph and stuff so come on out
and see us on saturday night if you're
into that uh failing that uh don't
forget to watch hawkeye in about oh 10
minutes have you been watching uh
yellow jackets
i've seen the pilot i'm catching up on
the rest i'm digging it dope it is so
good they're up to episode five so
[ __ ] good watch uh yellow jags i got
no skin in the game other than this
[ __ ] pretty damn good show and stuff
um but uh there would be no show for us
here to talk about tonight we're not for
the guy stand in my left give it up for
director mark bernard air director mark
bernard
[Applause]
and that
is fat man on batman for this batman
beyond
drink
all i'm thinking about right now is
hummus so i forgot the name of the show
uh that is fat man beyond for this week
i'm kevin smith i am mark tune in next
week same that time same fat channel
spot guest.com or youtube.com kevin
smith jeff's kiss ladies
happy new year
[Applause]
this is the cat
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask of anything every saga has a ten
year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens when jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith
[Music]